Changed my life.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes.
Dan Dodi.
Yes,
we're live.
What's up brother?
How are you man?
Good to see Ya.
Good to see you too man.
So,
uh,
for people don't know.
Uh,
I met Dan way back in 2012 does,
that seems like a long time ago now.
It seems like,
uh,
at least half of my life,
which is not even close to,
is that true?
I mean why is it like five years?
It was five years ago.
Yeah,
I thought a half years ago.
Well that was back when it was October
of 2012.
I thought there was only two months left
in the world cause I thought the Mayan
calendar was correct and it was December
21st,
2012 was going to end the world.
Okay.
So yeah.
So you fucked off and went to Montana to
go on a boat ride with us.
Yeah,
we took a,
we took a canoe down the Missouri River.
That was fucking awesome,
man.
Isn't that wild?
It's one of my favorite trips ever.
Was cold,
really cold,
like not fun.
Cold.
It was cold.
That gets sucked.
But once he got moved and it was fine,
you know,
and I,
I learned about Merino wool.
That was the important,
there was an important lesson like the
first light Merino wool like that people
don't know if you're ever in a cold
area.
It's so important that you have a base
layer of Merino wool cause that shit
gets wet and you stay warm.
Even if you sweat in it,
you stay warm and calf as much as,
as the synthetic versions at all.
It's weird like some people really liked
synthetics in some weird way like use
them or did you,
do you have I have this,
I smelled terrible.
So you actually don't care.
I like them both but I just,
you know,
working with those guys for so long and,
and firstlight I got used to it.
I like it.
But I use synthetics for 10 years before
that and I mean I didn't smell good but
didn't really care.
A lot of mountaineering people like some
synthetics because they dry quicker.
Yeah.
But I feel like the,
one of the best benefits of the wall is
that when it is wet,
it's still retains your warmth.
And I don't mind being a little moist.
Well,
the synthetics will keep you warm too
when they're wet.
Just it's slightly different value.
Like cotton will not right it all night,
but it's synthetic like a kathleen that
Patagonia is,
is there other things?
They also will,
they won't,
they won't kill you.
Um,
but yeah.
Uh,
the,
the Marino has some other better
qualities.
Yeah.
Well the stink things huge because I
fuck it smelled terrible.
That was a fun trip,
man.
That was actually the first episode of
that show that I,
um,
that I fully kind of shot and directed
myself.
So that was kind of a big stage from,
it was fun.
Yeah.
I just basically hung out with Kalyn two
per week.
Will you have,
when you have Cowan,
when Collin has a,
like a captive audience,
he's the funniest man alive.
I will never forget these things.
I won't share them.
Let's go ahead.
I these scenes from that campfire,
do you remember the ravine calmer?
Oh,
I remember,
I remember him taking a shit.
Literally 10 feet from our campfire is
asked,
sticking out and we put a flag in it.
I took pictures of it and how that shit
that we put it in aluminum flag on it
and stuck in there.
I've never touched another man's shit
other than his,
I tried to set up a hunt for myself last
year and the brakes and it just ended up
didn't happening.
But uh,
it's one of my favorite places.
It's so lonely out there,
but so amazing.
That area is so,
it's such a perfect place to introduce
count and I to the world of hunting
because it's so wild with multifaceted
too.
You have a lot of history there.
You have the,
yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's one of those areas where it's a
complete wilderness experience cause
you're on the water right there.
You weren't,
we're not crossing roads like we got
dropped off at the end of a road and
floated to basically the next row down
the river,
which is a big deal.
We floated 40 miles down over the course
of,
what was it?
Six days is one of my,
one of these bucks.
Yeah.
That one right there.
That's the buck right there.
Hey Buddy.
Hey Fella.
That's a different time.
That was in Wisconsin.
That was one where it was constant,
that video that you just put up.
But um,
when we did do that,
man,
it was a,
that was where Lewis and Clark had made
some stops expedition.
And that's where one of the coolest
things about doing it with Rinella,
cause he knows so much about the history
of the United States and the,
the settling of the United States and
also the Nez perce Indian stories that
he would tell us.
Oh yeah,
he can touch shit years.
Yeah.
And that's when I heard the story about
the,
what the real story,
the original story about the Leonardo
Dicaprio movie.
The revenant.
Like what really happened?
Oh,
he told her to a movie.
Okay.
Yeah.
He told me that story.
The actual story about the guy that got
left behind and crawled back many,
many miles.
What's the guy's name?
I don't remember the actual guy's name,
but there's so much they made up in the
movie.
It's just to kind of brutal.
Yeah.
It was a freaky movie.
It wasn't pretty.
The grizzly bear attack.
Yeah.
It was a real freaky thing.
The real grizzly bear attack.
So man,
I bet the real grizzly just kind of
swatted that dude once and then just he
fell down and it left him alone.
Why do you think that?
Cause that thing would have torn to
pieces.
It was a giant bear too.
And I just fuck bears,
man.
They scare the shit out of me.
I wonder really the average length of
time of a bear attack?
Like how long has it lasts?
Two seconds.
30 seconds.
Well the um,
that movie grizzly man,
apparently the audio of him getting
killed by the bears like seven minutes
long and listen to that.
That was terrible.
No,
it's not real.
The one you listened to online's not
real.
Oh no shit.
It's fake.
Yeah.
The actual audio was never released.
Life is a lie.
Yeah.
I have somebody send it to me too,
but then I looked into it and Werner
Herzog and the woman who owns the actual
audio,
they got rid of it.
They destroyed it.
They never listened to it,
and Werner Herzog actually told her to
destroy it in the documentary.
So the one,
when you hear it online,
it's just fake.
And then once you know it's fake and you
listen to it,
you go,
oh,
this shit's fake.
You like you can hear it.
You want to hear it.
I'm not going to listen to it again,
but you can.
Sure.
Yeah.
We really want to see,
do you find that grizzly man audio who
you hear it and you go,
oh yeah,
this isn't real.
That's one of my top five movies of all
time though.
It's a great movie.
Credible to one of the funniest movies
ever as far as unintentional comedy.
Oh my God.
That's funny.
Was it the sheriff?
The sheriff goes,
well,
I thought he was retarded
here,
like screams and shed
all the fox audio bear attack.
Why is it echoing here?
The echo that was done in the room.
All these,
these voices,
these supposed to be in the woods.
Yeah,
that's definitely,
that audio is unquestionably done in a
room somewhere.
Oh Sierra.
It's fake horse.
See now you know those mother fuckers,
they got us.
Do you think they benefited from
creating that?
Probably.
Yeah.
Somebody probably put up some youtube
ads and made some cash.
All right.
It's entirely possible.
Or they just did it for fun.
It sounded like people were having a
good time.
You guys,
the guy's yelling.
It sounds like you can almost kind of
like here in his yellow.
It's like,
Holy Shit,
someone's going to believe this.
This is so ridiculous.
But it's supposedly lasted seven minutes
because they're just start leading them.
Wait,
so what's that?
What does that stat that's not from like
the real audio last bought actual
audience because the bears not trying to
kill him.
It's just eating them.
Yeah.
Cause bears apparently,
well I've seen bears kill moose in
videos and they just start eating them.
They don't kill him right away.
I know all of them down to wolves do
too.
They just eat right away.
They start right at the back end and
start eating you.
They don't,
they don't bother.
They don't have the decency.
Like at least a mountain lion kills Ya.
You know,
cats kill.
Yeah.
Bears and wolves.
They just eat you.
I guess they just don't need to,
they don't need to incapacitate
everybody there.
Well,
I think it's also a thing with
omnivores.
Omnivores,
I think don't have that instinct to
instantly kill.
And that's interesting.
Yeah.
But that doesn't make sense though.
My theory sucks because of wolves,
because wolves.
Yeah.
So maybe it's interesting.
I don't know.
I mean they,
they do that because they have to,
right?
Like that's how they,
they take,
they take on a running animal itself
kills.
They snap at the legs,
right?
Yeah.
And then they just,
it's the easiest,
softest part of me just start eating on
the back end.
I was listening to a podcast today about
wolves and Idaho where they were talking
about how when you go deep into the back
country where people can't get to or
where it's very difficult,
really rocky terrain,
the wolves are just running,
ramping out there.
They just have so many wolves there.
Ever seen one in the wild?
No,
she put that on your list.
I actually did see one,
you know Berta I think,
but it was at twilight and it was dog
sized and it ran across the road and it
was a little too big to be a coyote.
Sure.
In my mind.
But I thought I saw a wolf for like two
seconds and it was a squirrel.
So take that thought.
I've seen a couple of the most memorable
we where we were in a valley in Alaska
and it was dusk and uh,
you know,
just too massive mountain ranges on each
side.
And uh,
I don't know,
it might've been the honest,
somebody yelled and somebody spotted one
across the river and we went and looked
at it and it was,
it was men.
My memory is failing.
He was either pure white,
I think it was pure white and it just,
I swear to God it's shown,
I it just like emanated light and it was
the most like regal,
beautiful,
just like perfect,
perfect.
And it just sort of trotted along the
river and disappeared back in the woods
and they're amazing.
And I was thinking about it this morning
on a hike here,
I was looking for mountain lion tracks,
but you know,
the sign at the trailhead says,
gives you warning about mountain lions
are out here for sure.
Yeah.
I never really,
um,
I don't know.
The only thing that ever gives me pause
in the woods is a grizzly because you
know,
Steve and I,
we got charged that once and ever since
that happened,
my a bear radar is more intense and it's
just such a freaky animal.
Yeah.
When you see what a grizzly really is,
essentially a thousand pound giant wild
dog,
have you seen those in the wild yourself
yet?
Grisly.
Yeah.
No,
never seen a grizzly.
Not In the wild.
I've seen them,
you know,
live in a sanctuary and I've seen a lot
of,
oh no,
I did see a Grizzly,
I saw small grizzly in Alberta,
uh,
last year.
Yeah.
But it wasn't that big.
It was like maybe six and a half,
seven feet.
It was on the stand where you're pretty
close.
Yeah,
it was very close.
It was like 30 or 40 yards from us.
Yeah.
But it took off pretty quick.
But it wasn't a Grizzly,
like they had some trail cam photos of
like fucking tankers.
They were Goddamn VW buses.
This was like a juvenile.
So it was probably like I said,
probably like six and a half feet or
something like that where I live in
Bozeman.
So it's literally a line right where we
are.
So south of us is the Gallatin range in
the Madison Range,
just full full of grizzlies.
But just north of town,
there's the bridger range and a couple
other ranges too.
And for whatever reason that is an
impasse to the population of bears.
Why is rls?
Do they have any ideas?
I mean,
it might be,
um,
just physicality.
And my actually Steve Rainelle would be
the one that I've heard him talk about
this.
He would know exactly,
but it's either a physical impasse or
it's,
it's the human and the proximity to
humans,
the of the,
of the town and all this.
But the way that it relates is that,
you know,
if I'm going to go hiking with my little
baby boy,
oh boy,
I choose to go north just because,
you know,
I don't think I would always thought
that way.
And I carry bear spray.
Usually I carry a pistol.
I don't,
I probably will in the future just
because that guy he was from Bozeman got
attacked last year.
Yeah.
He got tore up and that was horrific.
Oh yeah.
His scalp is hanging off his head while
he's making the video.
It was a gnarly,
and he wasn't hunting,
he was just hiking.
He was scouting and um,
he used bear spray and it didn't work.
It was a sow with her cubs.
Yeah.
So that's about,
I dunno,
50 miles from where I live.
It's where he got hit 60 miles.
Something like that.
Close.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Nothing to mess around with.
Man.
I think it's awesome that they exist.
I really,
I think it's so cool that they exist.
I don't want him to not exist,
but at the same time I don't want to be
near them.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't want to encounter him.
So it's,
so uh,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm more sensitive to them now.
I have really have a deep,
deep love for them.
Sharks on the other hand,
we could just kill them.
What's weird?
People are getting like really touchy
feely about sharks because they hear all
about these sharks getting slaughtered
for shark fin soup.
Oh,
like,
yeah.
The governor I think of New York caught
a shark fishing totally legal and not an
endangered fish at all and he got so
much hate because people who,
it's like we were talking before about
science that so many people want to
argue things online but they don't want
to actually like look into like what are
the studies that had been done and how
much do people actually know?
What is the,
I know people want to have an opinion.
They have this like narrow window of
information and then I'm just going to
run with my opinion and say,
fuck you for killing that shark.
Oh yeah.
You know,
it's like people have time necessarily
to go investigate everything.
They have an opinion about an issue.
No,
but they do have time to tweet about it.
Get Mad at the governor.
Was it the governor,
was it the mayor of New York that that
got in trouble for the shark?
Well,
you didn't get in trouble because what
he did was totally legal and they cooked
it and Maaco shark is delicious.
[inaudible] ever had.
And the Puerto Rico,
they serve,
they serve shark everywhere.
Like you go to a food stand,
they fry shark,
put it on a stick.
It's a fish machine.
It's an ocean.
It's an ocean out there.
It is.
New York governor sparks anger after
killing threatened shark.
But it's not threatened.
That's not true.
Why does it say threatened shark?
That's not a threatened animal thresher
shark yet.
I don't,
I don't think it said threatened.
Right.
It's it fresher.
Did it say in the headline?
Oh,
threaten.
Oh yeah.
So threatened.
I don't think that's true.
I do not think that's a threatened
animal.
I'd have to look at it.
I have all three species of thresher.
Shark is listed as vulnerable by the
International Union for conservation of
nature because of their declining
populations.
Fishing for them is regulated in the
National Oceanic and atmospheric
administration,
but it is not illegal.
Okay.
Despite its legality,
you and patrons of the ocean,
Lewis said the killing and subsequent
photos were a porn.
Oh,
it might be a Twat and worked against
those trying to conserve dwindling shark
numbers.
Um Hm.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
Well maybe he's right.
I know that some of them are not.
I Dunno
man.
I mean you can't really control what
kind of fish you catch when you go
fishing.
And if you catch a fish that's legal.
I,
what do you do the problem with catch
and release?
This is a dirty secret,
ladies and gentlemen,
because people do go catch and release
fishing and I've released fish before.
A lot of them die.
It's,
it's kind of weird.
Like is that a secret still you think
for some folks?
Yeah.
Not sure.
Are you sure?
Oh,
absolutely.
I mean,
think about it.
it'd be like taking you and I,
Duncan is underwater for five minutes
and putting us back you,
or even worse,
shoving a fucking barb through your face
and then drowning us because all we're
doing to it and we're literally drowning
them.
Literally.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
some people use barbless hooks,
which are better,
and the inside of the mouth of a fish is
very different than our mouth.
So like,
I mean,
there's Pratt,
right?
There's best practices to,
to,
to harm the fish as little as possible.
And I think,
you know,
that's why I say,
sure.
Yeah.
Fly fishing with barbless hooks.
You can.
Most likely you can.
Most of them are going to be fine,
but a lot of our night,
it's a weird practice.
I just don't,
I don't putting them back.
Yeah.
Well it's just,
yeah.
I'm,
I'm not,
uh,
I'm not a catch and release fish
fisherman.
I'm not even a huge fisherman.
I love to eat it.
I love to go to Alaska,
catch a buttload of fish,
come home and eat it for the rest of the
year.
I need to go halibut fishing.
Jesse,
do cause I've done that yet.
No,
no.
I love how I've gone fluke fishing.
I've caught flounder before,
which a little baby halibut's but
they're delicious.
But halibut is supposed to be like one
of the most delicious fish to catch and
cook like right away.
Oh that's amazing.
I mean I,
it's um,
it's one of those rule of fleshy white
fish,
kinda like grouper,
grouper.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
like chunks the hell,
the deep fried,
like,
like a well coated and deep fried it
the,
the thing about how,
but if you overcook it though,
it's like chewing on a sock.
It just gets tough.
Real fascinated.
That's true of other white flesh fish
like that too.
But no,
it's delicious.
It's not the most exciting to catch.
Well,
there are giant doors.
Yeah.
You just like holding up his heavy ass.
They're so alien looking to two eyes on
one side of their head and they flatten
out at the bottom of the ocean.
You know that they're,
I migrates.
Right.
Really?
They start swimming up and down,
eyes on each side and then started a
part of their,
uh,
maturation processes.
They flip over as they're getting older.
Yeah.
As they're getting older and there I
literally slides onto the other side,
but it stays there once it's,
yeah.
It's not like I can't go back and forth
on that side.
How fucking weird is so weird looking at
it looks wrong.
Yeah.
Let me see two eyes on one side of their
head.
Their bodies flattened out and it's full
of so much good meat.
Oh yeah.
Oh Man.
It's like as heavy and like my aunt and
uncle live on Kodiak island.
We've been going up there since I was a
kid and I mean it's,
you know,
it's,
that's as much meat as a deer,
right?
You get to 200 pound halibut,
which isn't the most common.
They can be way bigger than that too.
You're supposed to release the really
big ones though,
right?
Don't they say that?
I Dunno.
Maybe I,
yeah,
I'm not sure.
A friend of mine caught one and there
was apparently enormous and he was
furious because the guide,
they went fishing with a guide.
The guide cut the line because it was so
big.
Do you think he just couldn't get it in
the boat?
No,
no,
no.
He said,
look,
we got to let this go because it's a big
breeder.
Oh.
And that these,
these big ones are responsible for
keeping the populations healthy.
And because this guy made a living off
of fishing,
he's like,
it's our responsibility to cut the
sleeves.
And the guy was like,
what are you talking about?
He's like,
this is like,
he didn't know that that was going to be
an option.
Yeah.
And so he's pulling up this thing where
he described it as like the side of a
wall.
Oh yeah.
Like the wall of a room.
It's like,
it's fucking huge.
I don't know if it's true how,
but,
but I know other fish,
you know,
sometimes the big ones don't eat that
well.
You're just not sure.
It might not have been.
It's not like he's going to get that
mounted.
I doubt.
Right.
Like a 400 pounds.
They say that's true with deer too.
Like I've never eaten a really old deer,
but they say old deer just do not taste
that good.
It can be it.
I know they can be worse for sure.
Shoot an old dough.
That was mo mo,
mo.
That's right.
Yeah.
And he said it was rough.
I mean,
how did it change rooms over a winter?
But my little brother shot me a deer and
gave it to me for Christmas and it was
the first slightly off tasting animal
that I've tasted in man,
seven years,
you know,
and I've been eating a lot of animals,
over my course of time.
Um,
you know,
we're talking about media,
which I've worked on for a long time.
I don't anymore,
but uh,
I a lot of animals and they all tasted
exceptionally good.
And my brother shot this one and um,
I don't know what it was.
It was cold.
He killed it.
Um,
and it got dark and he had to track it
in early the next morning and it's,
um,
did he got shot it?
No,
no,
he hit it.
Well it,
it,
it died fairly close.
Um,
but then it was,
it was pretty gnarly and I even mean,
so I made sausage out of it and try to
eat that and that was hard to get down.
We have a,
we have a couple pounds of it left
still.
It just wasn't good.
Hmm.
That's weird.
Well,
maybe it was a tarsal glands or
something.
Like was it in the Rut?
No,
it was muzzleloader season in,
in December in Minnesota.
And uh,
I don't know what it was.
I really don't.
Yeah.
Well you hear stories,
you know,
I,
I'll tell you what,
man,
that was one of the things that really
got me into hunting,
not with just the,
how cool that trip was and how amazing
it was and how bizarre it is to be out
there.
And total silence.
No cell phone signal.
You don't hear.
Not What do we see?
Like maybe three people the whole week
we were out there.
Yeah.
Two boats,
maybe.
I don't even remember seeing him.
I remember we saw a dude's tent and he
had like a little a woodstove and I was
like,
Steve,
we got to go the stove.
Fuck is this.
This guy's got a stove inside of his
tent because he used to stay at warm and
his tent.
We were freezing our dicks off and then
we saw another guy who had a deer in his
boat.
He had shot up.
Oh yeah.
Remember that guy?
Yeah.
That was a memorable meal,
man.
Yeah,
that was going to say the food was so
good.
Once we did shoot that deer and we
ate it that night,
it was like,
good Lord.
It's still,
it's the best meat ever and pos,
there's so much connected to it,
you know?
It's not just that.
It's like you went to a restaurant,
you had a delicious meal.
It's like,
no,
you like,
you busted your ass for five days
humping over mountains.
Finally put a stock on a deer shot.
The deer killed it,
dragged it back to camp,
cut it up,
butchered it,
and then we ate it.
And like,
and then when Steve took that dough head
and buried it underground because,
uh,
what does that Guthrie Book?
A big sky.
Yeah.
Right.
It was in this book.
Yeah.
I think it's,
I think that's the name of it.
I think that's the name of the book.
Right.
And in that book he talks about cooking
a deer head under the ground.
So Steve wanted to try it.
We soaked burlap sack I've ever,
it was incredible.
It was really good.
It was incredible.
It was like some sort of exotic smoked
pork or something like that.
Yeah.
But then,
yeah,
we ate everything,
man.
We ate the liver,
we ate the heart.
We,
when we ate it all,
it was amazing.
Do you still have a freezer full of meat
right now?
Shot an elk.
Nice.
In October.
So yeah.
And I,
I had shot a deer in November,
but I ate that near pretty quick.
Yeah.
I had a doubt of the season last year
and this year for the first time.
A long time.
I've been eating more local pork and
beef and I'm just so sick of it,
man.
I can't wait until this fall again.
And now when are you going back home?
Back home from here?
Yeah,
I'm going home.
Um,
a week from two weeks from yesterday.
I have two commercial freezers in the
back.
I could hook you up.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm going to turn it down.
How could you get it back?
Um,
let me think about it.
I can,
I can go buy cooler stuff.
Go buy a small Yeti or figure something
out and get you some,
I have one of those Yeti hoppers at home
I could give you that.
That makes me really proud that like,
you know,
I was there the first time you hunted,
now you're going to hook me up with me.
That's good stuff.
I live off it now.
I don't buy meat anymore unless I go to
a restaurant.
It's very rare that I go to a store like
a butcher shop and buy meat unless
there's something I'm preparing,
it's just not as good.
It's just actually not as good.
Well or I find that it's,
it's different.
It tastes like a soft,
lazy animal.
It's weird like when you eat a steak,
like from a butcher shop,
I mean they taste good,
they still taste good,
but it tastes like,
like this soft almost sick thing.
Like there's a difference.
Chink,
grass fed beef.
And that's one of the things that I
noticed like way back in the day when I
first started learning about grass fed
beef,
I'm like,
well,
what is the difference?
And people explain to you,
oh,
there's a difference in the fatty acids
and what's,
what's healthier about it is these
animals are not supposed to be eating
grain.
And when they eat grain,
it's bad for their body.
And that's why they're so fat.
And the marbling is actually them being
incredibly unhealthy and like,
Huh,
okay,
so I'm gonna try some grass fed meat.
And it was so expensive.
And then it was a small,
like they're smaller,
like the stakes are small and it's a
darker meat.
I'm like,
hmm.
And then I remember eating it thinking,
wow,
this tastes really different.
Yeah,
it does.
Like a grass fed steak tastes different
than a grain fed steak.
They look different when you lay them
out side by side.
Oh yeah.
But then you take those and then you put
an elk stake next to it and you go,
okay,
that's the real meat man.
That's what you're supposed to be
eating.
You're supposed to be in that deep,
dark red meat that you eat it and you
just want to run through a fucking wall.
It's like it's got energy in it.
Like it it fee.
It makes your body feel different when
you eat it.
So what is it?
What do you think that is?
What is,
is that,
is that a a psychological thing?
Do you think that it's actually
biological in the meat?
It is better.
There's something in there and more for
you.
How do you,
how do you make sense of that for
yourself?
I have a terrible unscientific theory
and my unscientific theory is things
that run fast or better for you.
That's why fish is really good for you
cause it's hard to catch and they've,
they've swim fast.
Deer are great.
They run fast,
rabbits are great.
They run fast.
Cows just sort of wander around,
you know,
that just meandering and slow theory.
But it makes sense that we have more
cows cause I guess it's just all right
there corral those bitches.
Well you know my buddy Adam lives in uh,
Australia,
Adam Green tree and in Australia they
have wild cows where cows at one time
were domestic but they broke loose and
they've been for many,
many,
many generations living wild and they're
extremely dangerous.
Yeah.
Especially the bowls.
Like when you watch cowboys riding bowls
and you're like,
wow,
this is crazy.
We were like,
yeah,
that's a fucking big scary animal.
But again,
a domestic animal that is not fighting
off predators.
It's not,
I mean it's just,
it doesn't want you to fuck with it.
It's got these giant watermelon
testicles and they're just full of piss
and vinegar and that we don't eat those.
If Pete for people don't know,
when you buy meat from a cow,
you're buying meat from a steer and want
to steer is a bold.
It cut his balls off and he's young.
So his testosterone stops.
So there's bodies mushy and soft.
Yeah.
But these bulls that Adam sees out in
the bush in Australia are super
aggressive and very dangerous and one of
his friends was torn apart by Juan Gord,
like really badly.
No,
they lived,
but they had a med vac to safety at
tours,
guts open and you know,
he was,
I don't even think he was hunting it.
I think like he was just in the wrong
place.
The wrong time.
They see you and they just fucking
charge.
Yeah.
It means a reason why they have those
goddamn giant horns.
Yeah.
What's the saying that uh,
you cut,
you cut into a male animals balls off
and they stop thinking about ass and
start thinking about grass.
So it's literal.
Yeah.
They stopped trying to get laid and they
just eat,
they just keep eating and they just,
the lack of testosterone make some soft
and mushy.
Whereas I'm Cam Haynes shot of water
buffalo in Australia and he said that he
had one piece of meat in his mouth for
half an hour trying to chew it down
while he was practicing archery.
He goes,
I'm not exaggerating.
Chewed piece of meat for a whole half
hour.
Yeah.
What's it say about us though?
Are as as humans though.
I mean you could easily make an analogy
there between cows and then a wild
animal and us.
I mean nobody's more domesticated than
us.
No.
These things we domesticate.
I think we are,
you know where the domestic cater
somehow,
but I think we're even more
domesticated.
Like if you could eat one of the duck
dynasty guys.
Oh Man,
they would cook up good.
Oh Oh mushy.
And
you know there would be so much
flavoring and marbling and plus they
probably eat a lot of sugar.
So there's probably like a lot of like
sweetness to the meat.
Yeah,
I'm not advocating,
it depends on what your tooth is though.
If you're used to eating wild animals
and eight one of the duck dynasty guys
would taste like shit.
That's true.
But if you eat McDonald's and ring
dings,
what's,
what's the ring thing?
Look,
you're one of those little hostess
things.
So chocolate covered,
cream filled jammies.
I might have to get one of those.
I haven't had them on those disgusting.
They look great.
Like,
Oh,
who is it going to enjoy this?
And then as soon as you eat it,
you're like,
what the fuck is wrong with me,
man?
Yeah.
I love just,
I had some tacos.
I got to town last night and uh,
had to go to the first Taqueria.
I saw it was the best.
We have legit Mexican food in La.
The Montessori does not have next,
not really right.
Not such good Mexican food,
but Colorado has some really good
Mexican food.
It does.
Yeah.
It,
the,
the line of that I think stops at
Colorado.
Maybe why I'm going,
I don't think has it been north into
Montana?
You're,
you're in a dead zone where you are is
amazing though.
It's worth it.
You could take a trip for Mexican food
because where you are,
it's like,
I feel like,
I mean,
I almost feel like I shouldn't say this
on the podcast because I don't want
anybody moving to Bozeman is already on
her foot to list.
It's everybody.
I mean it's the cat's out of the bag.
It's not,
you're making sure you're not spilling
the beans here.
I know,
but I mean,
it really is a special place.
It's the people are so nice.
Yeah.
They're not dumb either.
It's not like uneducated.
No,
no,
no.
It's actually that county has the
highest percentage of phds in America.
What bozeman really nail.
Look it up.
Fact.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's a highly educated population,
but it's also not like boulder where
they're like,
or my God save the butterfly.
You know,
there are no national about their
approach to nature.
It's balanced.
You can find some,
you know,
you can find good yoga,
you can find your boob and stuff,
but there's also a rancher right next to
you.
It's really interestingly like diverse
troll.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
It's diverse some ways.
Not with mostly white.
Yeah.
No.
Moving there from New York and,
and uh,
that is my least favorite thing about,
about Montana and not a whole lot of
flavor.
No,
but there's so many good things about,
and the,
the landscape,
like what you get to see when you're
there.
So stunning.
And the access to the is the huge,
it's a huge thing too.
I mean,
I'm in Bozeman from my house in,
I don't know how many fin fought four
different directions,
three different directions.
You can be at a trail in 15 minutes and
it's just,
and it's just endless.
You know,
you can get on a trail ride side of,
Oh man,
I can't talk right outside of Bozeman.
And you can go if you wanted to for days
through the yellowstone ecosystem south.
Yeah.
And just keep going and keep going and
keep going.
I mean it,
it connects you to,
I mean real big wilderness,
the kind,
the kind that you can,
I mean in Alaska you find it even
bigger,
but I think in the lower 48 yeah,
it's unparalleled.
Man in the lower 48 is about,
it's about as wild as it gets.
And that leads me to what I wanted to
bring up to you today because I saw this
today where trump is his,
his challenging some of the protection
of certain national monuments and some
public lands today.
It was something that came out and like
I told you fuckers,
I knew this was coming and there were so
many people that were telling me that
trump is going to protect our public
lands because his son is a hunter and
like,
listen man,
that guy worships money.
There's money to be made in delisting
these public.
Look at this trump order could roll back
public land protections from three
presidents.
This is going to have a shit storm on
his hands though may play there so we
could hear exactly what he says of
America's natural ratio sis
and I can tell you the group that's in
here right now,
they're really doing the job.
Rightly said,
they doing a good job.
No,
we're going to take care of Alaska too.
Don't worry about it.
And they protect the ability of the
people to access and utilize the land
which truly belongs to them and belongs
to all of us.
Secretary Ryan Zinky is doing an
incredible job and he never overlooks
the details.
He's a detailed person.
Soon after he was confirmed,
we had a snow storm,
big one,
and he was out there on the steps of the
Lincoln memorial shoveling the snow all
by himself.
And he's a strong guy.
He did a good job.
Part the fuck am I.
Very,
very good job.
Proud of heard the first 100 days we've
taken historic action to eliminate
wasteful regulations.
They're being eliminated like nobody's
ever seen before.
There's never been anything like it.
Sometimes I look at some of the things
I'm signing,
I say maybe people won't like it,
but I'm doing the right thing.
What the hell?
This is so weird that that's a
president.
But the way he communicates,
did you see when he,
he just pinned a purple heart?
Jesus.
He just pinned a purple heart on,
on a return vet.
I got lost.
His leg just happened last couple of
days.
It's the most awkward and weirdest.
It is
the weirdest single thing I've ever
watched on a screen.
His,
his body language and his,
uh,
what he does.
It's bizarre.
Really Bizarre.
And what does it
say there in terms of like what the uh,
actual rollbacks mean and what the,
the issue is
here.
Let's go largely ignored order,
which trump sign.
The interior department could lead to
the reshaping of 24 national monuments,
including the Grand Canyon Parish
Shan't,
national monument,
Grand Staircase Escalante National
Monument,
and the Bass and range national monument
as well as the host of Pacific Ocean
monuments,
including the World War II valor in the
Pacific National Monument though
Interior Secretary Ryan Zinke,
he cast the move as a way to include
local voices in the decision to
designate monuments.
The review of the antiquities act,
which is the first signed by President
Teddy Roosevelt in 1906 stands in stark
relief two years of bipartisan work at
conserving lands.
Wow.
The move comes after Western Republican
lawmakers,
including Utah Senator Orrin Hatch
complained that Obama overused the law
to overprotect land.
How the fuck do you overprotect land?
It kind of protected,
but don't overprotect it,
but I don't know,
man.
It's history
weird.
The worry is going to be that this would
be in the beginning of a,
of a larger pattern.
It's a slippery slope.
Well,
I,
what I wanted to,
you know about,
and what I think most people don't,
when you talk about this,
the vast majority of the people in this
country live in these communities and
cities and towns and you know,
even small towns they do,
they don't understand how much of this
land that we live in is just this
incredible,
bizarre,
uh,
experiment in like the people having
the,
the actual American people owning this
incredible swath of public land.
I mean,
it's,
it's wild.
Like what you're talking about.
Like you can walk for days and days into
that.
Yeah.
I think they don't know that exists
necessarily.
And I think even to me,
more importantly,
they don't understand the impact that
that actually has on people and what it
actually means to be able to be part of
something like that.
It's,
it's a really deep,
important thing.
And I think that people just,
you know,
you get your postcard tourists and you
say,
Oh,
I love the national forest.
I love the national parks and let's
drive around and take pictures.
And that's great.
That's fine.
There's a big industry there.
It's very helpful to the economy and uh,
but there's something way deeper to
that.
Brings a lot of people.
Um,
and I will even say culturally,
something really deep there that we
shouldn't be fucking with.
No.
You just shouldn't be messing with it.
Well,
it's been there for a hundred years,
110 years.
It's the conservation part of it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But the land itself has been there way
longer and that's,
you know,
sort of like the deep time.
Part of that is what really interests me
is because,
you know,
step out into that in the right context
and,
and you're all of a sudden,
you know,
you're,
uh,
you're playing with something way bigger
and more powerful and more impactful by
just being part of the landscape that,
you know,
but you're right.
Yeah.
The,
the conservation thing is present and
real.
And,
uh,
the,
I grew up in Minnesota and North Dakota
and my,
my first wilderness trip was in the
boundary waters of northern Minnesota.
It's this million 8 million Acre
wilderness of lakes that are
interconnected by trails and you can go
out for weeks at a time and canoe across
the lake and then carry your boat to the
next lake.
And there's camp sites and it's just,
it's paradise.
It's where I fell in love with the idea
of wilderness.
It's actually where I fell in love with
my,
for the first lady that fell in love at
the same,
I was on a church trip.
Oh No.
Yeah.
And uh,
but you know,
so what I,
you know what I'm saying as far as it's
shaping people and its importance.
I mean that's first trip into the
wilderness changed my life.
Like,
and that's a,
that's a pretty mild way of saying it.
It,
it,
it shaped who I am all the way.
Well that gets us to what you're doing
now because you,
you stop working for 0.0 and we talked
about on the last podcast that you had
done a lot of these wilderness therapy
trips where you'd take like troubled
kids that have lost their way and their
parents don't know what the fuck to do
and you would take them out into the
woods and live with these kids for
months.
Yeah.
For a long time.
Just crazy to think about like that,
but make sense.
Like just the five days that I was out
there six days or whatever,
when I first went to Montana with you
guys changed the way I thought about
wilderness cause I really had never
been,
I mean I'd kind of been to like wooded
areas.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
But I maybe I went to yellowstone,
I was a kid,
but I didn't really remember it.
It's a different thing man.
And then we went to Alaska.
Right.
And that was,
to me,
that's another level of which it was
listened to you on that trip.
You were like,
fuck that place,
we shouldn't go to that place.
Sure.
It was uncomfortable.
But um,
I'm glad we went though in retrospect.
Right.
I mean,
and I'm glad you went just because of
the level of how deep out we are.
You know,
the,
the Missouri Breaks in Montana,
you're out there,
but in this spot and in southeast
Alaska,
we were really out there and you can
feel in the air
fell.
I fell off of this like six foot drop.
I slept and just,
and luckily I just landed good.
But I was like,
man,
you could fuck yourself up up here and
not be able to get out of here.
Like,
especially if you do a solo trip.
Oh yeah.
No Bueno.
No,
totally.
Yeah.
I'm addicted to that.
That feeling.
Yeah,
that sort of immense.
Kenny,
it takes you over.
You are so tiny.
You are not,
you know,
you're not in charge anymore.
It doesn't care about you.
That's the thing.
Like the thing about like Prince of
Wales is this solitude,
this sadness.
That's beautiful.
It's really weird.
It's a weird feeling that you get,
you just like it.
There's no denying your lack of
significance in this particular
environment.
It doesn't give a fuck about your credit
cards now.
It doesn't care if like cell phone,
it doesn't care who you know or where
you live or what kind of car each,
it doesn't give a fuck.
Yeah.
It's just tooth than Fang and claw and
rain and constant rain and beauty.
Just unbelievable beauty with the,
like when the sun does color coaster.
Oh yeah.
I mean you're just in hell and all of a
sudden you're on the top of a ridge and,
and the,
and the sun peaks out in a rainbow pops
up and the like the technicolor hyper
vivid,
just like crazy green.
It's a,
sorry about that.
I have cold,
uh,
that place as a personality.
Yeah.
Right.
But being in wilderness,
I've been in wilderness spots all over
the globe.
It's what's so fascinating to me is how
they all have a different vibe.
They'll have a different like life.
And it is,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
I mean,
sure it looks different,
but there's a,
like a felt sense or a feeling you get
from places like the Brooks range in
Alaska is the northern most range of
mountains and it runs east and west.
And then above it is the Arctic,
the Arctic plane,
and an Arctic Ocean.
There is something about being up there.
And especially I think in the summer
when the sun doesn't really go down.
It is,
it is,
it feels like being on a different
planet.
But man,
I don't know if I have the worst to
describe it,
but yeah,
man,
I mean,
and that's what I said.
I'm addicted to.
I am.
And I,
you know,
I moved to Montana for professional
reasons,
but then also because it's where I
wanted to live.
And so I get out hiking all the time,
you know,
I train,
I hike with,
that's Kinda how I stay fit.
Um,
but I come,
I need to figure this out because I come
home from that feeling like I just like
got started.
You know,
I've missed the deep immersion of the
woods when you were working for meat
eater and you constantly on those trips
or any time that I spent over,
I think there's something that happens
after,
you know,
depending on how long,
the longest I've stayed out at a time is
a 40 some days.
Um,
but there's some that happens,
I don't know,
a day,
two days,
three days,
five days in where you really just kind
of let go of the regular,
you know,
I don't know.
I think he's actually physiological,
some of it,
but whatever.
It could be just psychological too,
but something shifts,
you know,
when you do a real expedition,
when you do a real thing where you're
not,
your brain's not half stuck back in all
the other stuff.
So yeah,
I go hiking and I love it,
you know,
all the time and we get out in the
woods,
but it just doesn't really do it for me.
I feel kind of unfulfilled.
That's interesting.
So you,
you just got so addicted to being out
there,
completely disconnected that you,
when you go on the hike,
you know,
you could always just make it back to
town a couple hours.
Oh yeah.
It's just like a little,
I'm trying to think of like an analogy,
but it would be like a little taste.
Yeah.
It would be like maybe like a five
minute
porn session versus a week long like
lovemaking session that of your dreams,
right?
Just like a little,
uh,
yeah,
a little teaser,
just not as fun.
Do you,
do you plan on staying there?
Is that,
I think so.
Yeah.
I mean we think about we definitely
won't move back east.
We would either move somewhere out here
or stay there.
It gets cold as fuck in the winter
though,
right?
It does.
Yeah.
Not,
not that call to action.
Like not compared to where I grew up in
Minnesota.
It gets really cold for a long time and
Montana where we're at.
I used to do that,
but uh,
global warming,
something,
something it's different this year was
pretty mild.
The year before was really,
really mild.
You know,
like 35 average temperature.
Really?
That's it.
Yeah.
It's not that bad.
I thought it was like 35 below.
No,
you go northern Montana up in the
highline area.
It'll start to,
you know,
more of a deep freeze.
A lot more wind is kind of a nice little
protected.
We should stop talking about Bozeman so
people hear me telling you we're going
to get people into it.
It's um,
well just another factor and that it is
the,
I think the third fastest growing county
in the states right now.
Wow.
So,
well it makes sense.
When I was there,
we went there,
took the family in there last summer.
I was like,
this place is magic.
So pretty.
I got a couple of other spots though
that saving.
Oh yeah.
Don't tell anybody.
No,
I'm not.
Gonna um,
when you were in the brooks range,
did you put a like masks on to go to
sleep?
Those,
you know,
sleeping masks,
they say,
yeah,
I just use a tee shirt.
Just cover your eyes.
Yeah.
They say you have to because if you just
try to like sleep,
you'll wake up a couple hours later and
be all be welded.
Oh yeah,
no,
it's weird.
It's weird.
It's cool.
It's a very,
it's a perception changing thing to go
up there and watch the sun literally
just kind of like,
you know,
kiss the horizon and then just keep
going.
And Yeah.
I went to anchorage couple of years ago
in the summer,
we were there in July.
Me and my friend Ari went fishing up
there and we did some shows up there and
uh,
it was weird.
It's like two o'clock in the morning,
it was a light out.
And we're like,
what in the fuck is this like and that
people are coolish shit.
That's another place.
There's something about like those
people like Alaska even more extreme
because something about those people
that they deal with nature in a way that
everybody else just doesn't.
Oh yeah.
Well they have,
yeah,
all the time.
Whether it's gnarly.
I mean,
you can't walk out your house for more
than 10 miles before you have it,
you know,
giant,
massive in front of you peak.
The ocean's right there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean anchorage is a,
it's a weird place too.
I love it.
Yeah.
It's really interesting too because you
think of it as like a bunch of like
lumberjacks and fishermen and Weirdos
and like people trying to run from the
law or something like that and you get
there and there was like honk free
quality.
There's a bunch of people with gay
rights signs.
People beeping their horns as they drove
by.
I'm like,
oh,
this is not what you think it is.
Craft breweries and really good
restaurants.
Like,
oh,
okay,
this is,
it's not,
it's not like Hicks.
I feel like it has a little bit of
flavor of the Pacific northwest of
Seattle and Portland,
but then then a,
a big dose,
a weird to a lot of weird,
a lot of extreme.
I mean these are,
these are people that are there.
That's,
this is where they're going to live and
die.
Yeah.
And,
you know,
it was a grizzly bears everywhere.
A lot of Minnesotans and folks from
where I grew up there,
there's a big connection.
A lot of people move up to have moved up
to Alaska.
So I,
like I said,
I grew up going up there fairly
regularly in the summer.
So who did you say lives that you know,
that lives on Kodiak Island?
My Dad's sister family.
That's a scary place.
Those bears are fuck and John.
Yeah.
They onto the biggest brown bears in the
world.
Uh,
they might be,
I think I've heard that the Kamchatka
Brown bears in Siberia,
in,
in Russia across,
I don't know if that is Siberia,
but up across the,
the water there,
um,
they might be bigger.
I could be totally wrong,
but I saw this video of this guy.
Do you remember that show?
That was on a,
it was called the hunt.
It was,
um,
a show that,
it was interesting because,
um,
James Hetfield of Metallica was the
narrator of it.
And people were so angry at him for
narrating this thing that they were,
uh,
talking about boycotting metallica when
they played some music festival.
I never watched.
I remember you talking about it and
then,
yeah,
I know what you're talking about.
And it was about a bear hunting,
right?
Yeah.
It was about brown bear hunting,
which is a really controversial form of
hunting because you don't really eat
those things.
I mean,
you kind of can,
but they taste like shit.
Well,
the coastal ones special,
they're just eating rotten fish all the
time.
Yeah,
well like animals tastes like what
their,
what they eat,
which is really,
yeah,
I mean it makes sense,
but it seems pretty counterintuitive.
I dare trump to try to take away some of
those Alaskan wilderness areas and they,
I mean,
the way the real worry is that he's
going to let people drill in them and
they're going to destroy something.
That's the real worry.
The real worry is the reason why he's
releasing or relaxing some of these
regulations is that he wants to let
industry get in there and as soon as
they start fracking and polluting wells
and rivers and it's just,
it's fucking dangerous man.
It's just not,
it's something that if they do fuck it
up,
it could be fucked up for a hundred
generations.
Yeah.
Did you ever live in New York City?
Not In the city.
I used to live in new Rochelle,
which is right outside of the Bronx.
I lived there for seven years or so.
And uh,
if there,
if there wasn't the existence of central
park and I lived in Brooklyn,
so prospect park,
if those two green places didn't exist
while I lived there,
I would have probably lost my mind or
just moved.
Right.
I feel like these big areas of
wilderness we have,
you know,
as we will not be okay as,
as humans.
I mean like individually.
Sure.
It is it going to,
here's my worry.
My worry is that,
um,
you know,
the general American public or the
general public doesn't have enough
connection or real life experience to
know why to care so much and you know,
that's a big deal and it's,
um,
I don't know,
there's a lot of different angles you
can take on that.
There's the,
there's so much,
but there's just something that,
uh,
I wouldn't,
I mean if it really gets intense,
I'm going to have to basically drop what
I'm doing and do everything I can to,
to stop them from,
from harming these places could be done.
My,
my real concern is not just this,
what's going on now,
but the future and then also when you
really consider it overpopulation,
I mean there's seven and a half billion
people on the planet now and the most
recent census,
yeah,
this is a,
that's a half a billion increase over
the last,
I don't know how many years,
but it hasn't been that many.
It was 6 billion just a few years ago.
I remembered that was a number that they
bandied about like a decade or two ago.
Now it's seven and a half.
Like what happens when it gets to be 30
like where are we going to put these
motherfuckers?
What is the carrying capacity?
Then it must apply,
amber.
Yeah,
it's weird.
We're like rats on a sinking ship.
Yeah.
We're just scrambling everywhere.
We're everywhere.
We're like,
it's going to have not another animal
like us when we're on every fucking
patch of land.
You can find.
Yeah,
it's weird,
but we're awesome.
Except these wilderness spots,
right?
Look at this current world population.
Is that real?
How do they know that?
Births today?
It's based off averages.
Look at the burst today.
You could watch the,
the numbers just roll in.
Oh my God.
The difference between the birth today
and the death today,
that's incredible.
That's why it's moving so fast because
we're dying slow as fuck.
Population growth today.
So the,
the average 139,000 people today,
44 million this year.
Oh my God.
It's weird,
but
that's scary.
And what's the u s 400 million?
I think we're 300 plus Mexicans.
Three 26 it says c but that's,
they're not counting.
They're not counting all the people that
snuck in.
I just don't think they know.
Like when,
when they'd say Los Angeles,
let's say Los Angeles,
20 million.
I'm like,
okay.
And what about the Mexicans?
Yeah,
like,
cause there's a lot,
and I'm not anti Mexican in any way,
shape or form.
Ladies and gentlemen don't,
I'm just looking at this pragmatically.
Yeah.
There's a fucking shit load of illegal
aliens here,
which I support also.
How many people are here that any given
time that don't live here but are here
on vacation or working here for like a
week?
That's a good question.
Yeah.
Just added people for hundreds of
thousands,
I would imagine.
Yeah,
probably.
Yeah.
When you get on the four oh five and you
had to San Diego and it takes you six
hours and you go,
what is this?
Like what have we done?
This massive humans.
Yeah,
there's so many of us.
But when you get here and you realize,
oh you,
you guys don't have any weather,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
But you could also,
you know,
go 30 miles outside the city and have
that same either.
Couldn't ya?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
But you know,
you don't get the same Taco stands,
right?
Yeah.
I get it.
I like,
I love cities,
man.
I miss it.
I miss living in New York City.
I really do to you.
I wouldn't trade it at this point.
You know,
I was younger and single in New York,
had a,
had a fun time and moved to Montana,
have a family now it's kind of perfect
for,
for uh,
where I'm at in my life,
so I don't really need anything else.
Yeah,
that's the balance,
right?
It's like there is no really perfect
place.
It's like there's places that are
perfect for certain things.
Like if you're a comedian,
Los Angeles is the best place to either
Los Angeles or New York.
I prefer Los Angeles.
There's a lot of clubs,
there's a lot of Comedians,
like most of the best comedians in the
world live here.
It's a great place for us to network and
we work together and stuff like that.
And if you,
if you want to be in that business is
probably the best place in the world to
do it.
So that's one of the reasons it keeps me
around here,
plus the podcast and all that jazz.
But for peace of mind,
it's not the best place.
No.
Does that actually fuck with you?
Yes.
Yeah.
The numbers of humans is just,
it's untenable.
And you're close to North Korea.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
But if you know what man,
if they nuke California,
where are you going to go?
You know?
I mean the whole thing's going to be a
mess.
Yeah.
Might as well.
You might be better off if it lands on
your head.
That's why we say about asteroids,
like you don't want to be that guy in
the movie that like is like storing food
in his basement and staying up all night
to shoot vandals and because people are
trying to steal your canned goods.
That doesn't sound fun.
Not like a healthy life.
No,
you don't want to live like that.
And then what happens?
You die of old age.
Die Of old age.
Protecting your canned goods.
Yeah.
In fight or flight your entire life.
Fuck that.
And then just let that rock land right
on your fucking head.
I used to stress out a lot about what
are the perfect place to live was I just
gave that up.
It doesn't exist.
Doesn't exist.
There's,
there's places you don't want to be
caught dead like Florida.
I liked Florida.
How dare you.
I like it.
And the part Sarah,
so no,
my wife was raised on Captiva island,
which is on the east coast.
Okay.
Like Key West is pretty dope.
Yeah.
Down there.
It's pretty cool.
Yeah.
That's a good place.
You just want to drink and take naps or
fish or,
yeah.
Yeah,
There's some cool stuff down there,
but it's just,
Florida's just so fucked up.
It's,
they've,
they've done such damage to Florida.
Would their oxycontin regulations know
one time there were more oxycontin
prescriptions in Florida than they were
the entire country combined?
Seriously?
Yes.
I didn't know that was insane.
How is this recent?
As,
as like recent in these,
in these late struggles?
Yeah,
there was a documentary that I called
the Oxycontin express that was on
vanguard.
Wow.
And,
um,
these people that,
went down there,
they went undercover and uh,
saw how easy it is to buy opiates down
there.
They would,
they have these one stop shops,
they have these pain management centers.
We'd go in and he'd say,
Hey doc,
my back is killing me.
Doc said,
you need pills.
Go right next door.
So he'd write your prescription,
you go right next door,
you get the pills and then boom,
you're off to the races.
And they didn't have a database,
which meant that you could go to Dr
Jamie and say,
Jamie,
my back's killing me.
Dr Jamie gives you a prescription.
You buy some opium pills or whatever the
fuck they are.
And then you come to me and he'd go,
Doctor Joe,
my back is killing me.
I'm like,
Oh,
you see where this just being sourced
there and then so sold elsewhere or did
we purposely made the regulations lax
there so they can make more money.
So people were buying them and then
bringing them and selling them and
Kentucky and up to Ohio,
the,
that's why they call it the Oxycontin
Express,
the highway that led from Florida to the
rest of the country.
It sounds evil.
Yeah.
It was sick and you know,
a lot of people lost their lives and a
lot of people lost like who they were
because of the addiction.
Wow.
Yeah.
The numbers were insane.
Like Google the numbers.
Like what,
what were the numbers of oxy cottons or
oxycodone?
I still don't know what the differences,
and you've seen the reports lately
showing that the uh,
the life expectancy or the early death
rate of middle age white men
specifically lately,
it has dropped for the first time in,
I dunno,
dozens or cause of pain pills.
Yeah.
Well,
part of it and calling them deaths of
despair.
Woo.
How they're being Jesus written about is
literally deaths of despair.
It's,
it's,
yeah.
Jesus.
Oh,
it's heavy.
It's real heavy.
That's a heavy,
he's been a spate of articles over the
last three or four months.
Just that's really diving into it.
And it's guys,
it's men.
Here it is.
Doctors in Florida prescribed 10 times
more oxycodone pills then every other
state in the country combined.
Wow.
And this is now,
right?
What ends this article from,
this was actually from 2011 on NPR when
the,
probably when it came out.
Ah,
there we go.
I can get the updated one.
Yeah,
it doesn't matter.
It's just,
it's a crazy place.
Let's just put it that way.
Despairs one of the scariest words,
despair.
When you hear about someone like despair
and lonely,
those are two like really?
So that's the other word that they're
using is,
is his loneliness has been there.
Now measuring it and loneliness is,
is as or worse of a health issue in our
country than smoking heavily smoking
there.
There's all this,
there's this new only misses.
Loneliness isn't overpopulation
coincided with lowliness the same time
we're thrust further and further closer
together and we don't know each other
and we're more and more disconnected and
lonely.
And it's literally,
so there's a whole new,
um,
I dunno how new,
but it's called interpersonal
neurobiology,
which is the science of our brain
wiring.
And physiological wiring on how we're,
uh,
yeah,
this is one of the articles.
Loneliness might be a bigger health risk
than smoking or obesity.
Whoa,
that's dark dude.
It's dark.
But you know,
with the,
in my life,
the experience I've had in my life,
I'm,
when I read that I'm like of course Duh,
Duh.
It makes sense.
Yeah.
We are a disconnected people.
We are electronically,
digitally connected in a crazy way but
in a human way and it's killing.
It literally is harming.
Awesome.
People are dying and it's crazy.
It's crazy stuff.
Fascinating that like feelings have an
effect on your health.
Like the feeling of loneliness to
feeling of despair.
It's not like you could eat your
vegetables,
you can get your exercise in and you,
if you feel despair and you feel
loneliness,
your body is actually like being harmed
by that.
But there's a real like practical reason
for that and that's because we are,
when we come out as babies,
we are the most dependent individuals.
So like are,
you know what I mean?
Like on your parents,
on your mother.
We are completely socially dependent
when we're born completely.
And so,
you know,
April Maslov's hierarchy of needs.
You ever heard of that?
So it's like,
you know,
to be okay,
you have to take care of breathing and
water and your basic functions.
But there's,
there's been studies recently by these
neurobiologists that are showing that
these social needs are just as,
or even like come before some of these
physical needs.
There's,
there's,
it's,
it's crazy man.
And there's literally,
there's a book called social by a guy
named Matthew Lieberman.
Like you gotta check it out.
And so what they are finding is that
there's like two,
uh,
parts of our operating brain,
and this is,
you know,
going to be me paring it down,
but one is the analytical thinking,
deciding thing.
And the other is this social awareness
sprain,
which is always like always checking in
on how am I in relation to others.
And it's also the part of their brain
that actually we can,
you know,
like the metacognitive part and the part
that I can,
they call it mind reading,
but really it's just,
it's just by US sitting here,
I can kind of get a sense of how you
feel and what you're thinking right.
Just by the,
the connection that we have and just,
it's part of who we are.
So when our analytical brain is offline,
this other one,
the social one pops on immediately.
So,
so what they're theorizing is that that
is like the fundamental need for humans
in safety and survival is how are we
relating to each other as a,
as a group.
But it makes sense if you look,
I mean to me it makes sense in,
um,
you know,
we are social animals.
We forget that I think,
but you look at other species of monkeys
or wolves or whatever.
I mean,
you know,
there might be a period of time where
say,
Oh,
a wolf will,
we'll get kicked of a pack for a while
and he'll go do his thing,
but eventually come back to a pack.
It's not safe for us as humans and
animals,
social animals like these to be
isolated.
It's not.
And,
and so there's all these parts of us
that just,
if we're not connected to other people
in a,
in a very direct and true way,
there's these sort of a deep down
emotional and physiological,
uh,
fears that come up.
Right?
And they,
and they're the real,
and that's what the neurobiology is
showing,
which is really interesting.
And when we can just think about that,
but they're actually showing it now that
if we're not really connected to each
other,
we're going to be freaked out.
We're not going to be okay.
And,
um,
you know,
I really believe that this really drives
a lot of the internal struggle we have.
And we're really,
and this is part of,
you know,
getting into it,
but that's part of my,
what I'm trying to bring into the world
and my platform now is,
is just to,
you know,
stand up and say,
hey,
we need each other and we can do it.
It's not,
and for guys pitch specifically,
right,
it's such a social stigma of ours to not
be real or open or connected or
vulnerable with guys.
And uh,
and it's,
uh,
it's cool to see the science coming out
because it's,
I have all this anecdotal evidence of
being out the woods in the woods with
kids or being in a,
in a management with guys are running a
retreat or whatever this is of how
powerful it is to like set down all of
our differences and just be there with
them.
But now the science is really lighten it
up and yeah,
man,
loneliest.
I mean we can all think about a
loneliness isn't fun.
It's not a,
it doesn't feel good.
But the other,
this is crazy too that they're showing
that emotional pain,
the lights up the same centers of our
brain.
It's physical pain.
And that the one study showed that,
um,
an insult to someone had much more
painful and long term effects than
slamming somebody with a hammer hitting
their hand with a hammer.
So like our emotional pain literally
actually exists in the body.
Like it is actual pain.
And the reason that it's so
uncomfortable to feel our emotions,
which it is,
you know,
I mean I'll just say it is,
is that it actually hurts like actually
hurts.
I mean,
and there's like people say things like,
you broke my heart or I'm dying of heart
ache or whatever,
but the science is catching up and
showing us that this pain is actual,
it's real and we're not addressing it.
We're not even aware of it.
That's really interesting.
That's deep.
You know,
it's interesting too because what you're
saying about us being disconnected and
how unhealthy it is now on unhealthy
loneliness is it sort of confirms these
ideas that I've always had,
that the human race itself is not like a
group of individuals but a super
organism.
Much like the human body is like the
human body like requires all the
bacteria in your gut,
all the skin flora,
all the different things that compose
the actual physical structure of the
human body.
Whereas we think of it,
I think there's some nutty number of how
much bacteria,
how many bacteria cells are in your body
versus how many human cells and is he
far out numbers,
the human cells.
And it's just that we think of ourselves
as I'm mike and I put my shoes on and I
go to work cause I am Mike and,
but Mike,
you're a system,
you're a system of individual organisms
that are collectively keeping this whole
thing alive.
And when the imbalances off,
like when someone takes an antibiotic
and it fucks up their gut flora,
like literally you've like nuked a part
of your civilization and you know to try
to save something.
Like if you had some sort of a surgery
and you're worried about an infection,
which is kind of like an invading army
coming in and taking over part of your
leg that you have it operated on.
Yeah.
Or It'd be like slashing the tires of
all of our transport system in the
country.
Like that's how it got.
That's like the first things in an in
and out.
Yeah.
And even has an impact on your,
your health mentally.
Oh,
in terms of like how you feel and your
depression.
A lot of that has connected,
led,
legitimately connected to your diet and
how that affects your gut flora and it
affects the way your body produces
serotonin and dopamine and it's bananas,
man.
Oh yeah.
No,
I get it.
Is Scientists Bust the myth that our
bodies have more bacteria than human
cells.
Decades old assumption about Microbiota
revisited.
Okay.
What's the new new data one instead of,
oh,
so it's why you are as much.
Okay,
so they used to say it was 10 to one but
now it's one to one.
Okay.
Wow.
That's still crazy,
man.
It's still like you're half bacteria.
Yeah.
I like that analogy though of the body
is like a civilization or what it means
to think about if you're one of your,
I dunno,
one important neuron,
one cell neural cell or something
decided just to go rogue and not be in
connection with the rest of you.
Right.
I mean,
I don't,
that wouldn't work so well.
Right?
I don't know.
I don't know what happened.
Your body would probably get rid of it
and get it out of there or I don't know,
maybe so I'm just really reaching here,
but it's some sort of rogue cell at that
point.
Right.
Like cancerous cell or something and it
would probably be attacked.
So yeah,
if I think that if you'd take that
analogy,
you know,
our civilization here is we're hurting,
really hurting because we're,
we're really not,
you know,
we are working together obviously in
practical ways.
A lot of times,
you know,
work in commerce and you know,
the world is functioning.
But I think on a like a health and
fulfillment level,
we're,
we're missing something pretty deeply.
Yeah.
Well also like
let's talk about people that are
disconnected from actual humans but
connect them the cyber way.
Yeah.
Like how many people are like really
lonely in terms of like physical touch
and communication with friends and,
but they sit in front of their computer
all day and they interact with people
online,
which shows you like some of the most
unhealthy communities you'll ever
encounter are like online message boards
and forums where people are just the
anonymous and interacting with people
without what we were talking about
earlier.
Like one of the reasons why I like to do
podcasts with a person in the room.
I've only done one podcast ever through
skype.
Um,
and that was with John Anthony West
cause he was living in New York and he's
just this really important egyptologist
and I really wanted to talk to him as
the only way I could get them to do it
was to do it through skype.
So I did one,
I prefer to sit there with people
because I want to look at them.
I want to feel their energy.
I want to,
I feel like you and I doing this
conversation,
you get to understand each other.
Totally.
No,
I get it.
And I,
and I think I can hear it in your
podcast too.
And I think that,
uh,
you know,
and again,
I'm not going to keep hitting the
biology part,
but there's,
to me,
I think that it means,
I can sense that there's something else
in me is getting,
is triggered,
right?
If we were just talking on the phone,
there is something,
and it's might be this other part of
your brain,
but it's lit up right now.
Right.
Because I can,
I can spatially,
you know,
so you can feel where you are.
We can,
we can have social content,
all that,
all of that.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's set sense of connection.
It's that real.
Um,
I think,
and I think that is,
you know,
really apparent in your podcast is that
you,
yeah,
you sit here and you really connect to
somebody and just run with it.
And I think that's a,
it's a big,
it's a big thing,
man.
I mean,
I think of like,
um,
so part of what I do is I help
proliferate this idea of men's groups
across the country where guys get
together for exactly what we're talking
about.
It's just like,
you know,
the,
the intent of them is to,
um,
get together to challenge and support
each other's growth or personal growth,
you know,
and it's just a simple sort of protocol
and a simple sort of,
um,
uh,
design or are sort of,
there's a structure to it.
But the whole point is it's remedial in
a sense.
It's that,
you know,
our culture in general,
but guys,
especially in our culture,
don't have this,
this on fettered place to really show up
and actually connect with each other.
And it's a scary thing.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
um,
you know,
it's until now and still now,
but hopefully not too long.
I really like that stigma of not being
connected is,
um,
it's a big deal.
And,
and I think that back to the cyber thing
that you're saying like we can,
we can get that hit of Serotonin by
getting a,
like on facebook or instagram or
whatever.
We can get that.
But that pain,
I mean,
I don't even want to make a comparison
toward actually sitting,
sitting down with somebody and actually
feeling and,
and experiencing them.
Yeah.
It's,
you can't make a comparison.
No,
it's not okay to me.
I don't,
yeah,
it's just something different.
I'm in a tricky position because I rely
on social media to let people know that
I have a podcast coming out,
you know,
like right before the podcast I was
like,
what's your twitter?
So I can tweet it.
And then I also like to promote comedy
dates and to let people know about cool
shit that I find,
but the,
the interaction is so,
it's so weird.
Like especially there's like a bunch of
different kinds of interactions.
Like instagram is one of the weird ones
because the Qantas people all have
blocked pages.
It's like they're blocking,
don't look at me and they just say nasty
shit to people.
But they have these block pages.
It's like,
but I think that that's,
it's so funny how that seems to be like
it's so common,
but it makes sense.
It's like they're blocked off and
they're attacking people in Saint Shitty
things.
To be blunt,
I'm not even talking about,
to me,
I'm talking about like when I go to
someone else's page and I read
[inaudible] things,
I always go to that I go,
let's see if that guy is blocked.
Yup.
He's blocked.
How funny.
Like it's super common.
It's like this weird thing that people
are doing with each other.
What's not real interaction and I feel
like the people that are perpetrating it
are extremely unhealthy,
which is why they're saying such nasty,
vicious shit in the first place.
It's really,
really odd.
They're lonely.
Yeah.
No,
I mean in some way or disconnected or
disenfranchised or they feel inferior
and so they lash out.
They want other people to feel the way
they feel.
And so what I,
what I feel when you say that,
like one thing that's missing there is
empathy in that,
in that interact,
whatever that interaction is.
It's this removed story that you're
making up some,
some like whatever you want the world,
you know,
projecting your shit out into the world.
You're not actually slowing down enough
to,
you know,
you can sit here and give opinions or
whatever all day long.
But you know the,
but to what you said though,
it is a weird position,
but I think the way that things are
going,
so we are using these tools,
social media to connect us and to get
messages out.
But you know,
the way that the,
like the millennial generation is going
is that what they value and what they
want to spend their money on.
There's meaningful experiences,
which means,
you know,
generally speaking,
alive in person event.
And I think there is a wave of things
going back to this.
So,
you know,
as a tool we need that.
I mean this is amazing.
You know,
this platform,
this podcast,
you have the touching so many people or
just twitter,
whatever it is.
But then it can be used for incredible
good to bring two people together I
think.
And then,
and then so what's missing in that?
In that social media interaction.
Uh,
I don't know.
Maybe it balances out.
Maybe it doesn't,
I don't really know.
But a message in a bottle,
he just got to make sure it's a good
message.
You know,
you're not going to,
you're not,
you'd have to like be cognizantly aware
I think of how other people are going to
receive it without actually getting that
perception back from them.
You know,
it's,
and that's where it gets real weird and
you have to like,
I think apply the same principle
goals that you would in communicating
with other people,
like without actually communicating
with,
without seeing them,
without getting the social that look in
them in the eye and
where,
where a weird thing,
man,
this might not make sense,
but I'm going to bring it back to
connect to the wilderness stuff.
What we're talking about in this sense
of this sort of isolation and loneliness
that we have and for me in my life where
I learned to connect with others,
where I really learned to sort of give
it up,
let go be present with people was in the
wilderness.
It was,
it was doing that job out in the desert
with kids out there for eight to 20 days
at a time with these kids were,
that was my job.
It was my job to simply be with them and
in a way,
uh,
to be with them in a way that was,
um,
you know,
obviously we had a lot of boundaries and
everything,
but to be really real,
just to be totally real and honest and
straight forward call bullshit when we
saw bullshit,
be empathetic and it was just like this
crazy crash course in human connection.
And I happened to be out in the
wilderness,
but so what I think this is,
this is,
it'll tie it together,
but for me I started to feel way,
way,
way more human being out there in the
wilderness.
Like just being out there.
What was quiet being out there where
like,
you know,
if I sat on a rock,
I was sitting on a rock in the sun was
on me and all of my senses were engaged,
you know,
very aware of my body.
We were in these groups where we're
being practicing,
being very aware of what we felt and
being able to feel and express that.
And it just felt like,
um,
you know,
since then for me,
it all comes back to,
to being out in the wilderness.
But since then,
all the other things I've engaged in
meditation,
the men's group stuff,
all the other person,
even psychedelics,
things like that.
All the things that I've experienced all
for me tie back to that thing and it,
it comes down to what I feel is like
being totally as much as you can truly
present.
Yeah.
Like just,
just here right now.
Right.
And you can write a twitter message from
that place of being present.
Right.
That's fine.
I mean there's,
there's nothing necessarily wrong or bad
about that,
but um,
but don't check the responses every
three minutes for the next six hours.
I'm like a fucking maniac.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a matter of,
I guess,
rationing,
rationing some of the,
some of that social media stuff are
rationing some of that online
interaction with other people.
I feel like as time has gone on,
I've,
I've gotten much more of my online
interaction in like an educational forum
in terms of like interesting articles,
right?
Science things,
things that don't involve like a social
interaction or opinion as much as they
involve really fascinating facts.
Yeah.
Like,
um,
something that I've found today,
they think that North America might have
been settled by humans as much as a
hundred thousand years earlier than they
thought.
I saw that.
You see that?
I did.
It's insane.
Like that
kind of Shit freaks me out.
I love that kind of stuff because that
kind of stuff is just pure curiosity and
pure wonder.
And the imagination goes wild.
Thinking about what it must've been like
to be one of these early humans
surviving are trying to survive.
And if they didn't,
we wouldn't be here.
And these,
these,
uh,
mastodon fossils,
they found them,
the bones were shattered and there's
rocks nearby that do not seem like they
were broad anywhere.
So it was 1992 they were doing highway
construction near San Diego and they
found these odd looking bones.
And then they started doing these,
um,
uh,
studies on them,
and then they found that their mastodon
bones and they didn't have the ability
to do carbon testing and get a real
accurate assessment back then,
but now they do.
And so now when they're checking these
bones and the way these bones had been
shattered,
they're pretty sure that they had been
purposely like to get to the marrow.
Wow.
Yeah.
So that,
yeah,
that's a great example of a,
a positive benefit.
Yesterday I,
uh,
I,
I meditated for about 80 minutes or so,
and then I,
and I,
I sat up afterwards and I clicked on my
phone and open facebook.
And the first thing I clicked on it,
let's say with a video of a woman in
slow motion who stuck her ass out the
window of a bus and just shat the
street.
And I just,
I just,
I had to laugh to myself,
man.
I was just like in the zone,
you know,
I was in this beautiful place and then
we'll open once I says,
oh my God reminded me of Calvin's one
joke that shitting out of the car at 80
miles an hour,
that youtube video.
I think,
yeah,
I've,
I've definitely seen too many of those
videos.
I've seen too many videos of people
getting beat up too.
Too many videos of street fights.
Too many videos of people like
skateboard accidents where they fucking
flip and fall on their head.
It's hard to not watch that though.
Right,
right.
Hard.
Very hard.
Very,
very hard.
I mean,
I feel like there's something to be
learned in those videos.
Like I almost want to show my kids,
Hey,
don't try to do flips if you don't know
what you're doing.
Atlanta in your fucking head.
But you know,
I mean,
understanding the consequences and
having someone else do it so you can
learn from them.
They've already done it.
So here learn,
this is what,
this is why you don't fuck with a tiger.
See,
look,
the guy got killed by the tiger.
Now,
you know,
this is why you don't do,
this is why you don't do that.
Like there's gotta be some educational
value in those.
Ah,
yeah.
I'm sure that's all I can reach a little
bit.
Yeah.
I mean,
we have some pretty strong instincts in
us to say,
don't fuck with the dumb kids,
man.
It's like,
it's almost like dumb kids are there as
educational tools for the survivors.
It's like you're supposed to see that
one kid poke the tiger and get mauled.
He like,
shit,
I can't believe he actually broke into
the zoo and now bobby's gone.
You know,
like bobby,
like I mean,
that's the Joseph Campbell a story.
The hero that it
goes all the way back to the one person
who sacrificed their life.
Yeah.
And got killed by the Predator in front
of the tribe and so that the tribe could
survive and then they,
they worshiped that person for doing
that.
Yeah.
The,
the hero goes off,
learns some lesson,
brings it back to the community and
everybody's better for it.
Or You watch the hero get mauled,
he's a martyr.
Then you escape.
All the hyenas are eating them.
One of the things we taught or we've
worked with kids out in the woods was
that we call the natural consequences,
right.
Which,
which just means that when you do
something,
something else happens,
there is a natural reaction and it was
used a lot of times,
um,
in opposition or instead of of like a,
uh,
penalty system.
Right.
So if you do something bad,
we could,
we could lay this punishment on top of
you.
Like what kind of stuff I made.
Oh,
well.
So for example,
if,
um,
if somebody was going to harm themselves
or somebody else,
you got target,
you got to you,
we put out a tarp and your shoes and
everything will be taken away from you
and you,
and you couldn't leave the tarp like
that.
That was where you had to stay because
you can hurt yourself.
You couldn't hurt anybody else.
Wow.
Um,
so that was,
you know,
at some of that to do with their shoes,
ate them.
No.
What did you put them in your tent or
under your tongue?
And so they had this day,
like under a tarp.
Is that the idea or a,
if it was raining it happened.
No,
I mean otherwise it's just,
it was just basically a timeout.
Let's see.
Now you got to stay here.
You can interact with the group.
You're by yourself,
whatever.
Uh,
that's actually not the best example,
but I'll just use it.
So if you swore you could,
some programs would maybe have a point
system you get penalized for clients.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean that wasn't named Sol.
So yeah,
it wasn't really upheld.
I'm reaching for a good example here.
What I'm trying to say is that if you do
something Shitty,
generally you heard others around you
and things things happen.
And so what we tried to show is that if
kids would do something shitty to,
uh,
pay attention and that they would see
the harm they're creating themselves by
courier,
by harming other people rather than just
like,
you know,
uh,
in society,
just locking a kid up for breaking the
law.
Um,
it would be,
you know,
maybe if you break a window,
you in this other way,
you would go and actually see and
experience the,
the,
the shit that other people had to do to
fix the window and do all that,
you know,
more repairative type of justice system
rather than like a,
a penalty punitive,
punitive.
That's right.
Yeah.
Right.
So when you did take these kids,
like what was like the most extreme
example of someone who's like really
disturbed?
Because I would imagine there would be
like a big sort of,
uh,
like there was a lot of variables.
Like some people would be kind of fucked
up and some people would be really
fucked up.
It's probably a spectrum,
right?
Oh,
absolutely.
Generally speaking,
very few where I would say actually
fucked up.
Very,
very,
very few.
What were,
what was the case with most of them?
Um,
they were kids in families and like
communities that didn't know how to make
space for and deal with them.
They didn't,
the mentors,
they didn't have people to,
didn't have parents that,
that gave them the right direction.
I don't know.
You know,
like being a kid is,
is uh,
you're supposed to test boundaries,
right?
It's like that's the part of your
development in your ontogeny that it's
like you are defining your personality,
you defining who you are and you need to
test the boundaries.
And um,
you know,
some of the kids made,
uh,
only two.
I probably worked with at least a
thousand,
maybe more kids altogether.
Uh,
maybe that's a stretch a lot,
right?
For a lot,
for a long time.
And only one I went to bed at night
worried I might get my head kicked in
just one,
one kid.
And um,
maybe one or two other kids that I
walked away actually not enjoying being
around them.
Almost every other single one.
It was just like walked away as you do
about the one that you worried about
getting your head kicked in,
you know,
just kind of just kind of sat with it
and there's really nothing easy did,
it was just like initially or through
the entire experience that was through
the whole thing.
She,
that was through the whole thing that
was uncomfortable.
Fuck that.
What happened to him?
Oh,
he's doing now?
No,
I have no idea.
You know,
there's,
I mean there's laws and there's things
you don't generally get to stay in
touch.
Oh,
right,
right.
What was actually at a,
uh,
a state program.
So this was,
uh,
um,
in lieu of a jail sentence that came
out.
So,
so this kid was locked up.
Wow.
What did he do?
I don't remember.
I don't know.
Probably stole a car or beat somebody up
or,
I don't know.
He was just super aggressive.
He wasn't,
no,
but if he had that he had the,
I had the feeling that he had no empathy
for others pain.
Right.
And he couldn't feel that that's the,
that's the only time it ever got any
interaction with any of those kids ever
got,
you know,
that that sent chills through me.
You know,
that was like,
and maybe maybe I didn't feel in any
practical sense that he was going to
hurt me,
but I had the sense that if he did,
he wouldn't care.
Right.
Oh Wow.
Because there wasn't that connection and
the same thing we're talking about in a
sense,
like that's a thing.
Get dropped in a,
in a group of eight boys or young men.
And,
uh,
it was so funny,
like you could,
you know,
we worked with therapists with
therapists come in,
all this stuff,
but all like the fundamental thing I
took away from that experience was that
in order for these,
for these guys to grow up and sort of
move on and get going in their lives,
you know,
what they needed was just somebody like
me to just show up.
Like,
because we're really not complicated,
right?
And,
and so just let them air things out and
talk about better ways to do things and
sort of get some perspective.
Now,
you know,
we maybe talked about this last time,
but then they'd go home and not
necessarily have that support anymore
and be back in their old,
uh,
arena where we're,
um,
you know,
they're old friends and their old family
dynamic and all that and it,
and it,
you know,
it's hard.
That's a hard way.
And so I left that whole experience,
just feeling very strongly that a,
we can as a community and society just
way better with some simple,
simple changes we can do better at
raising our boys.
We just can't because done it.
When you have someone that has no
empathy though,
what can be done to instill empathy in
someone who lacks it,
if anything?
So I don't know.
You know,
if you go on that far end of the
spectrum where there's nothing,
I don't know.
And I don't know if that's possible,
but I do know that it's a muscle we can
practice.
Empathy is something that we can get
better at and that we can pay more
attention.
That's fucked up
young kid without empathy.
Like how,
what,
what sort of motivation do they have to
gain empathy if they feel like no one
has shown it towards them or I don't
know.
So that's,
that's it.
That's it.
Right.
So the motivation that you,
I believe you could show is for them to,
if they could let you caring about them
really in,
if they could really feel cared about
and what's incredibly sad but real is
that I think some people you know,
grow up in,
in,
uh,
their brains develop,
they develop as humans where they don't
have that.
And so the actual wiring,
the actual state to Ha to receive that
isn't there,
I think that that is possible to gain.
And you know,
there's been,
what does that a child called it,
you know,
have you heard of that book?
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I think it's possible in a much,
in a less extreme cases.
Um,
I mean in a sense that that's kind of a
lot of what I do is help guys become
more empathetic and the not just for the
benefit of others for the benefit of
themselves.
The reason why I brought this up,
there's a podcast I'm on radio lab about
Bernie madoff.
Okay.
And,
um,
where this guy contacted Bernie Madoff,
he sent him letters and then finally
Bernie madoff called them and they did
this interview together,
or the way it works in prison,
I guess at least the prison where Bernie
madoff is,
you get 15 minutes to talk on the phone
and then you have to wait 15 minutes
before he could talk again and then 15
minutes again.
And so they,
this is how they did the interview,
like 15 minutes on,
15 minutes off.
And after a while he sort of gained his
trust and he went deep into how this
whole deception started and how Bernie
made off.
If you don't know the whole story,
burning man off as a guy who had this
gigantic Ponzi scheme and stole billions
of dollars from people and it's called
Ponzi Supernova is the a radio lab
episode.
Wow.
And,
uh,
one of the things that was the most
chilling was how little empathy he had
towards the people that he ripped off,
right.
Whose lives had been destroyed.
His son committed suicide.
Um,
uh,
people like literally went from having
all this money to being so broke.
They were like dumpster diving and he
didn't care.
Didn't give a fuck.
Yeah.
I mean he,
he,
he had no empathy and he's a monster.
I mean it's,
it's really,
it's really interesting to see like this
guy's reaction to Bernie madoff's lack
of empathy and realizing somewhere along
the line like,
oh,
this guy does not care.
That was one of the things that the
investigators had said about him,
that it didn't seem to bother him at
all.
That he had done this to these people
that would,
what bothered him was that he had gotten
caught,
but it didn't bother him that these
people had been devastated.
What bothered him was like that people
had made money,
weren't giving that money back.
Like he'd called one guy and told him
the guide made like $9 billion.
He was worth $9 billion,
rather,
it's 7 billion of it had come from
Bernie madoff's Ponzi scheme.
And he told me how to give that $7
billion back.
The guy had a heart attack drown in his
pool,
which is kind of hilarious because you
can't live with 2 billion.
Yeah,
I guess.
Well,
maybe it's not liquid.
Maybe he couldn't give back the 7
billion.
Maybe it was impossible.
It was tied up in real estate and
holdings and this and that and the other
thing.
But isn't it amazing that one person's
reality could,
I would love to step into his head for a
second.
I want you to,
Bernie made him just to see what it felt
like.
I think that'd be very helpful to be
able to step into that because just to
see,
I can't picture it.
I just can't picture it.
Well,
I could also couldn't picture not being
able to live with $2 billion.
He like what?
What is it?
I,
it's that weirdness of the game,
right?
It's like you,
you score a hundred points.
You want to score a thousand point score
thousand.
He wanted score a million score,
1,000,001 score a billion.
It's like you never stop and people
never,
they never achieve peace.
Like that's what I always used to say
about Bill Gates.
Like why the fuck is Bill Gates still
working out here about him being the
richest and now he's not.
I mean he really did sort of find some
sort of a balance and now almost all of
his work is done towards humanitarian
efforts.
He's,
you know,
he donates a lot of money,
a lot of charities.
I mean,
a lot of really good work,
like post his Microsoft career,
which is like really kind of unique that
a guy sort of found his way,
found his back,
kept a shit load of money.
Don't get me wrong.
You know,
apparently he's got some stupid fucking
house with a submarine in the Pacific
northwest where like if someone tries to
break into his house,
he could fucking escape in a submarine.
I kayaked by his house one second.
Jim,
did they let you to secret service
fucking swarm you and ask you where
you're going?
Yeah.
Nobody,
I couldn't see anybody.
They're probably all lunch.
Are you allowed to just walk by his
house?
How's that work?
Well,
it was a private island,
at least the place that I was at.
I was just told by the guy I was with,
we were actually throwing crab pots
out of a Kayak and,
um,
I was just told it was his house.
I don't if it's mean house might have
been one of his houses,
but,
uh,
we were,
you know,
I dunno.
50 yards off shore and it was a private
island,
private island.
That's when you're,
yeah.
Paul,
when you got,
you're on an island,
you know,
what does an island,
Tyler Perry,
the guy that makes us shitty movies and
TV shows those awful shows.
Tyler Perry.
Yeah.
He has a private,
now he has a private room where,
I don't know,
you can't know if you know,
I actually feel,
uh,
some sadness for Bernie madoff.
Really?
Oh yeah,
man.
I mean,
that's,
I dunno.
He's as tortured as you know.
I think it's harder to feel empathy for
him,
but he's as tortured of human is.
I don't know.
Pick anybody maybe.
Right?
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe not.
I,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm projecting.
I don't know.
That's a fact,
but I don't know if you,
if you're hurting that many people,
are you,
are you kidding me?
Like you,
you,
you aren't feeling,
you don't feel all right.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a
weird line.
Like,
when do you feel bad for someone?
Do you feel bad for Jeffrey Dahmer?
Like how did he become that cannibal
murderer guys?
How did,
how did that happen?
You know,
like what,
what causes someone to go from like,
you have a boy,
what causes someone to go from your cute
little baby boy to being some monster?
Yeah.
Like how does that,
what is it about people that makes it
possible for someone to go even not for
to a monster,
but how about that young boy that you
were working with?
It had no empathy.
You worried about sleeping near like,
Woo Hoo.
What happens?
Like the developmental process of a
human being is way more fascinating to
me,
uh,
as an adult with children than it was
when I was a young man when I was young
man.
And I was single and I didn't have any
kids.
I just thought people were fucked up and
some people weren't.
The people that are fucked up,
fucked him and death penalty and like
kicked her ass.
And Yeah.
So I've been obsessed with this.
My,
all my life has been absolutely like
what,
what is this process of growing?
Have you ever heard of the novel
sidharth no,
by Hermann Hesse Hessa I'm not sure how
to say that,
but it's a classic novel,
an author from Germany and,
and it,
it chronicles the life of a young guy
named Sid Arthur.
But the whole book,
what it is,
is it goes through his entire life from
when he was born until he dies.
And in it are these like very specific
stages of life.
So He's,
you know,
he's like young wandering years and then
he needs to work.
So he goes to a city and he learns from
a,
from a trader and then he needs to learn
about love.
So he,
so he gets with a prostitute but,
but all in these big stages and that
book did something to me at an early
age.
I just got obsessed with this process of
maturing.
And there's a,
there's a term for it called ontogeny,
which is the,
the process of an organism's growth over
their lifespan.
It's just this natural sort of arc,
a tree.
Then ontogeny of a tree is,
it is a,
you know,
a seed that drops and then it sprouts
and then it routes and then it grows and
then it dies and it,
and it is,
yeah,
it's been an obsession of mine and you
know,
getting thrown into that work of working
with kids and yeah,
it's,
um,
uh,
I'm,
I'm so fascinated by it and I don't have
obviously any,
you know,
solid,
here's how it goes.
But,
but I've been looking into it for a long
time and,
um,
I just,
I think that,
oh,
anyway,
back to the book,
the,
I used to read that book out loud to
these groups of kids I was working on.
We'd sit around a fire at night and I'd
read a novel and it would be out there
for days.
So you've got the time to read a novel
out loud.
And,
uh,
you know,
it's just something poetic,
not about just the words but about
watching the life,
someone's life unfold as a whole story
and watching them,
you know,
I dunno,
grow up and yeah,
it's just,
it's this weird fascination I have and
it's specifically because in an all com
and it keeps saying it comes back to
that time in the woods,
but I only worked with males with boys
and it wasn't,
I didn't choose to do that.
I felt like,
do a lot of girls do the same sort of
therapy?
Yeah.
I think they must go with women too.
It's probably a problem with men going
out there with girls.
They'll do mixed a leadership group.
So like a male and a female from,
for both boys and girls.
But yeah,
there's always a girl with the girls.
Um,
but yeah,
man,
I just got obsessed with this.
What,
what,
how do we grow up?
What does it look like?
What's it feel like?
How come it's not happening?
Cause that's a big part of what I felt
as I looked around is that I think that
a lot of adult physically adult men walk
around with,
uh,
parts of themselves that are still in
their team,
six to 18.
You know,
like there's,
there's this human maturation process is
human journey that we all have available
to us that I,
um,
you know,
I think we're too busy a lot of times to
let it actually flow and happen.
Well,
I think that true,
that's true.
But I also think that there's a
maturation process that comes from
overcoming obstacles.
I would,
a lot of people just don't encounter,
they don't encounter difficulty so they
don't learn about them.
So that's part of it.
But I think that a lot of times,
even if they do encounter difficulty,
they don't let themselves actually feel,
they don't let themselves experience it.
Right.
Like everybody has shitty things happen
to them.
But you can keep that shitty thing at a
distance from you.
You're right,
you can't,
you can like kind of address it.
You can sort of,
I dunno,
act out against it,
but unless you actually feel,
you know,
I mean,
think about this,
this gets into things like,
uh,
trauma and resilience and how people are
able to move on from hardship.
Right?
And,
and a lot of the research,
um,
there's a,
uh,
psychiatrist called Bessel van der Kolk.
Never heard of him.
No.
Fascinating dude.
He's a,
he started working with the va in Boston
and,
uh,
worked with returning vets from,
um,
from Vietnam and then did this whole
lifetime of study about trauma and how
it comes into humans and how you can
move through it and how can heal it and
all this stuff.
And uh,
it,
it just,
it basically comes down to,
uh,
being able like to be more resilient,
to be able to get over things to say a
death in the family or an attack or an
assault or whatever,
whatever that trauma could be.
That if you don't allow the body and
the,
your system to actually go through feel
and process what's going on,
you lock it up,
you like it.
Uh,
and it,
it doesn't,
I mean,
it's almost like it gets implanted in
you somewhere and then it just festers
esters.
And it's,
and the cool thing is,
is that the,
you know,
the,
the science now is,
is showing the,
the very specifics of this.
It's not just,
I mean,
it's still theory,
right?
But it's,
um,
so I feel like I got off of what we were
talking about there.
Uh,
but yeah,
I,
I feel like,
like you said,
being able to overcome things.
Of course.
Absolutely.
And part of that is just to me,
um,
again,
speaking more from a male perspective
here,
but part of that,
and I think a lot of what our culture
says is,
okay,
is let's,
uh,
horse our way through this.
Right?
Let's force it,
let's push harder.
Let's,
let's conquer our fears and our
feelings.
That's,
let's not address it.
Let's just push,
right.
Run through the wall.
Basically we're taking the depressants.
Well,
right?
So that's,
that's the thing.
Then there's this other whole way to,
to get through hardship,
which is by actually surrendering to it
and letting your in this like brilliant
system that we have as humans to process
it and get through it.
Right.
And that's,
that's a way to wholeness and health in
some ways,
right?
I think they're both important.
I mean like,
yeah,
you need to be able to,
uh,
you know,
ignore the pain and,
and power your way up that mountain or,
or save somebody that's getting hurt or
whatever.
And then there's this other part I think
that needs to be in balance,
which is accepting what's happening and
getting through.
I just a way to accept what's happening
and let your body do what it needs.
Well,
I also think there's an extreme lack of
discipline that a lot of people have and
the discipline,
a lot of it comes from overcoming
difficult obstacles and understanding
the work that's required to get things
done.
Making these little leaps and bounds,
making these improvements in your life,
getting better at things.
I think those things are really critical
to the human mind.
Yeah.
I think the mind has desires and one of
the big desires is it has a desire for
improvement and his desire to achieve
goals.
And there's a lot of people that these
goals are laid out by other people.
These goals are like graduating from
third grade,
graduating from fourth grade,
a lot of shit that you don't want to do.
So these goals are
meaningless to you,
so you never feel like you've
accomplished anything that you actually
want to do.
And next thing you know what,
you're a 35 year old man working for an
insurance company.
You don't want to be there and you don't
have any real part of you that you've
nurtured.
You just sort of plugged you into these
other weird shapes and conform to them
and then you just want to go fucking
crazy and probably bitched about it all
the way along probably.
Yeah,
you probably complained and you're
annoying and you're a whining little
twat and you're out there just clogging
up the freeway,
beep it at people and giving them the
finger.
I mean,
that's a lot of humans that you run
into.
That's a lot of,
it's a lot of this life.
So yeah,
and that points directly to what you
know I do and what I'm building is,
is that,
so you take eight of those guys and you
set up a room and you say,
all right in this space right here,
fuck all that.
We're going to be actually honest and
say what we're feeling but maybe can't
even really access.
So like all that frustration,
all that shit,
whatever.
It could be anything that's so hard for
people to do.
Right?
Like what,
what kind of techniques do you employ to
get someone like say if you've got some
guy who was closed off and it's been
bullshitting his way through life and
then all of a sudden here he is,
this 35 year old guy that's really
troubled.
It's in a room with you.
How do you get that guy to open up
safety and safety leading by example and
being vulnerable by example.
And when somebody says it's part of this
connection,
like sitting down with somebody that if
you,
after one of these last retreats,
one of the guys came up to me and said,
safety is the new Iowasca,
which is maybe a strange thing to say,
but he said he'd been all over the world
doing drugs,
trying to find growth,
trying to find himself.
And when he went home and went to this
retreat and all we did was sit down and
say,
okay,
our intention,
all we're doing what we actually are
doing here is just,
uh,
making this,
you're not going to be,
you're going to be supported.
You're not going to be laughed at like,
like it's a safe space to do it.
And then you just,
uh,
you dive in and lead by example and that
example,
like plugs,
others right into it.
Like it's this amazing like symbiotic
thing that happens,
right?
And,
and people just sometimes break open,
sometimes cracks slowly open.
But you know,
all of a sudden,
so maybe after 35 years of only being
other people's program,
you get in touch with what you actually
feel,
what you actually want and who you
actually are.
It's just like this fucking,
it's like Holy Shit.
I think for a lot of people it's really
difficult to try to do what you actually
want to because you've spent so much
time rewarding yourself with material
items for these little accomplishments
that you've,
you've become in debt and you really
can't escape the system.
I mean,
that's totally real problem with people.
They have all the car that they're
leasing,
they have a house that they're renting
or even worse that they bought and then
they,
they're stuck and then they don't know
what the fuck to do.
They have to keep this insurance company
job and they're just rotting them out
from the inside.
Totally.
Yeah.
I mean there's like a whole society
built on,
on uh,
trying to keep you not who you are in a
sense.
I think,
you know,
but so what we're finding,
which is really amazing,
is that if you stay on that surface
level,
if you stay on that sort of,
um,
I don't know,
like,
so trying to improve yourself
goes so far,
but it's kind of like an iceberg thing,
right?
So like if your goal is to make more
money,
right?
And here's your goal and you're going
toward it and you and your,
I dunno,
listen to podcasts or you do all this
stuff and you try to figure out how to
do it,
how do I,
how do I do it?
How did it,
and you keep hitting a wall,
you keep getting sort of,
uh,
thrown down and you don't really
understand that underneath meanwhile is
this massive sort of like pent up shit.
And if you address that massive pent up
shit,
then all of a sudden getting to that
goal is a whole different story.
It's a whole different story.
It's a,
it's,
um,
it's like always trimming the,
like if you need to get rid of a tree in
your yard,
but all you do is every day you chop the
leaves off the leaves off.
But if you address that,
the roots,
the deeper stuff and uh,
you know,
and again,
there's a stigma against that,
especially for dudes.
Right?
So there's this,
like,
guys don't want to go to therapy,
guys don't want to get into woo hippie
spiritual shift do,
and they're annoying.
Sure.
Right.
They don't want to get into it.
Right,
exactly.
And I mean,
I don't know.
I don't know if I pull this off or not,
but I feel fluent than in a like,
you know,
broke.
Sure.
And fluent in,
you know,
like I've,
I've,
I've gone down that spiritual route two
and,
um,
well you recognize when the spiritual
route is legitimate and when the
spiritual route is like a rose as well.
Like sometimes even the spiritual route.
It's just something that someone has
plugged themselves into to try to find
some meaning.
Exactly.
Meanwhile,
it's not authentic.
Exactly.
Um,
so how are you doing this if you don't
mind me interrupting?
Like what?
So you're,
you're planning on taking guys,
like say,
say if I'm that 35 year old guy that
works in insurance company for example,
and I'm just fucked up and I just,
I'm going crazy,
man,
I need to do something.
Hey,
this seems interesting to me.
Wilderness therapy.
What does it mean Dan Dodi,
what does that mean?
How do I get involved in this and how do
you,
how do you get me out of this regimen?
Yeah.
So three things we're offering right
now.
And um,
the first is a is the wilderness route,
which is a like a six day expedition and
you can sign up,
pay some money,
and go out in the woods and change your
life.
Like pretty well climb mountains will go
fishing.
Well,
uh,
and all along.
So I'll set up this sense of safety in
this community and this sense of a
brotherhood.
And how many guys do you go with,
you know,
10 or 12 for that?
Just you and these 10 people.
A couple of the leaders in my couple
leaders,
right,
because you have to deal with
interpersonal disputes and all the
nonsense you're going to have to shoot
likely in shelter.
Right.
And I'm,
I'm working
with,
uh,
some guides to just take care of the
logistical stuff so that I can manage
the,
the group,
the group stuff more.
That's one offering.
That's,
that's,
that's uh,
that's kind of our capstone offering.
We're doing weekend retreats and we've
been doing these for the last six months
and they'd been just catching on fire
about 30 guys at a time,
uh,
in a lodge,
been doing them in the Berkshire's.
So out in the woods,
it's a couple hours from New York City,
30 guys there and just set up sort of an
intense weekend experience of practicing
this stuff and we'll hike and do trail
work and,
and all that stuff.
But more importantly to do with the,
the self,
you know,
diving into yourself with in the
presence of other guys,
which is,
um,
just,
you know,
I've done therapy.
I've been in therapy.
I'm not a therapist,
but,
um,
when it's been very helpful,
like if you work with a good therapist,
that really is really good.
I couldn't recommend it more,
but there's something about this,
these men's retreats,
which I totally understand sound on
attractive to a lot of guys.
I just like,
sounds like a lot of butt fucking yeah,
of course.
Of course.
That that is,
that is your,
that is the big first sort of response,
right?
Well,
it's,
Huh?
Tell me more.
We,
I can be open in the woods.
We what we made a,
uh,
one of our advertising videos for it and
it just starts out that a guy stands up
and says,
yeah,
I heard about a men's retreat and I
thought the first thing I thought was
this is going to be fucking awful.
And so I get it.
But,
um,
yeah,
I think we're getting further enough
along where the guys that are going
through this or are literally coming
back with the most positive feedback
that I could,
I couldn't write this shit like,
like changing their lives and just like
literally,
um,
because it's,
uh,
you know,
back to that thing we're,
we're offering a place for them to
accept a part of themselves that's been
offline for a long time.
That's a big fucking deal.
It's a really,
yeah,
it's all,
it's probably also a big fucking deal to
just separate from the high for a little
bit and just be outside of cell phone
range and be in the woods and just take
a big,
deep breath of fresh air and look around
at the wilderness and just realize that
this is,
this is reality as well.
And you're,
you've been plugged into this
civilization reality,
this,
this city,
this urban environment,
which is entirely unnatural and is only
been a real thing for the past couple
hundred years.
Like literally didn't exist for the
gigantic swath of humanity that,
that existed before that.
Yeah.
I think that it isn't the right word.
They're not really,
I think it does a couple deep things.
It,
it lights up this,
this,
um,
this neurobiology that,
that of us as social animals.
I think it,
it goes back to,
um,
more of a tribal sense of living too.
It's,
it's like all of a sudden you,
you went from being isolated and lonely
to heaven,
30 dudes who would honestly fucking do
anything for you in that moment.
And I got a buddy,
a good buddy as a return special forces
operator and he,
he sits in my men's group in Bozeman
with me and really struggled with coming
home and then found our group.
And within a month his life was back on
track.
Like I like just killing it man.
Just like kicking ass.
And you know,
I mean there is a connection between,
I wouldn't say the general military,
but the special forces,
you know,
you read books and hear about the aspect
of brotherhood and how they're there for
each other.
You know,
this is definitely a very different
venue.
But the,
I think the bond and connection that
that has created out of it is,
um,
and this is,
you know,
from,
from his mouth too,
is it's,
he went,
you know,
I don't know how many years,
several years in special forces w living
with in close connection to guys got
thrown home.
It was all of a sudden isolated and they
came into our group and just had this,
this closeness again,
and it just Bam,
just like back to back to killing it.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
I mean,
I've very aware,
I mean it's,
I've been scared to start speaking about
this for years,
man.
I mean,
it's very,
uh,
to me even I look at advertising for
similar man's programs and things that
done it just so turned off.
I'm like,
go,
seems weird.
It does seem that people need resets.
You need some sort of recent,
and we've talked about this before,
about,
we've both experienced those resets
through psychedelics or,
or through these hunting trips,
you know,
and these wilderness trips like,
but I think people get caught up in the
momentum of their daily existence and
all the requirements of that daily
existence and they become overwhelming.
You know,
like we were talking about like the your
lease that you have on your car or your
mortgage that you have in your house and
the credit card bills that keep coming
in your student loans,
you need to eventually get to and blah.
It's a fucking overwhelming grind.
Yeah.
And sometimes people need something that
removes them entirely from it for a
certain amount of time that allows you
just the fresh air,
not,
not just literal flesh air,
but the metaphorical fresh air of
allowing you to just separate from the
all these weird influences and all this
weird energy and momentum,
the momentum of the life that you've
created or that's been created for you,
that you're sort of trapped in.
Yeah.
Man.
Aye.
Aye Fit.
So that reset thing,
I mean,
I,
I think I want a warning is that if you
start getting a reset,
I mean from my own experience I needed
pretty regularly.
Yeah.
You know,
so the actually the biggest goal of,
of this,
of every man,
the organization I founded is to,
our goal is to get a million guys in
man's groups because that is the same.
And it happened.
So this last retreat had 30 guys show
up.
Um,
about 20 of them wanted to immediately
get a weekly group
to,
to basically continuing regularly
experienced the same thing gets,
it's like a hit,
you know,
like too about men in this culture where
there's not a lot of sympathy towards
men that are struggling.
And it seems like there's this thought
that men are the patriarchy and we're
dominating the world and we're almost
like sub human.
We're responsible for all these issues.
So men with issues like,
Oh,
cry me a fucking river.
What about women with issues?
What about Trans people with issues?
What about gay people with issues?
What about black?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Like a regular white guy with issues
like your issues are bullshit.
They can't like,
but it doesn't matter.
You are who you are.
You can't change the fact that you're a
white guy.
So if you're a white guy with problems,
nobody gives a fuck.
Can't they see that it all connects
though?
No,
they don't see that white makes
everybody else unhappy too.
When the dope man they don't because
it's not convenient for their narrative.
The narratives that you're responsible
for all the problems in the world,
even though you're just Dan Dodi from
Bozeman,
Montana.
No,
I get it.
But it's,
it's so,
I mean that's one of the most powerful,
so the podcast that I'm launching is a
self improvement podcasts for guys.
But instead of going to experts and
saying,
hey,
you know,
what's the best morning routine that you
can do?
Designing a routine or whatever.
I'm talking to regular guys and,
and asking them to share more vulnerable
than they would normally would because
that's what happens in these scenarios
is that we learn from each other just to
simple human fucking beings.
We're just like,
you know,
like one guy might share that he's
having trouble with his son,
for example,
with his kid,
he doesn't know how to do it.
And you know,
like no matter what,
I don't care.
Like a bunch of other guys will say
like,
Holy Shit,
I thought I was the only one feeling,
you know?
And it's just all of a sudden you and
it's back this isolation thing,
you think that your,
I don't think we're fucking special,
right?
We all think that we're still unique and
the actual,
if we actually took the time to connect
with one another,
we'd be like,
Oh wow,
we have a lot.
And just that,
just that is enough to,
uh,
drastically change somebody's Day.
And what is motivating you to venture
off because you were working for 0.0 is
big production company and they make no
meat eater and Anthony Bourdain's show
and all these different shows.
What's motivating you to step away from
that and start doing this?
This is what I've always wanted to do
and this is what I've been,
what compels you?
I want to help guys,
Eh,
yeah.
I just,
I,
and I know that I can,
you know,
even if it's just one guy,
whatever it is,
but working out there with these kids
and seeing all of this,
it just,
it just left me with the,
the deepest,
deepest satisfaction,
fulfillment,
satisfaction,
but also a sense of purpose.
It's like,
and then I tell you what,
man,
I had a,
I had a boy,
I had a son last year and when he came
out and there was something inside me
that said,
if you don't do,
if you don't act on what you know,
you can bring,
if fuck you,
fuck it.
Like this is your key.
Like,
like there is,
um,
I dunno,
I'm also,
you know,
I was born,
uh,
a fairly sensitive,
I could feel I was born a sensitive kid,
right?
I could feel other people's pain.
And when I'm,
you know,
working with these kids and now these
men,
I mean,
I dunno,
I want,
I want good for people,
right?
I want good for you.
I want good for my family and I want
good for,
I don't know,
I feel connected and I,
and I want to do it right.
It's a noble purpose.
I was just curious about like what,
I mean,
you,
you have a very promising career in a
lucrative career with 0.0.
So for you to leave that it has to be
like a really compelling sort of a,
yeah,
I mean,
that job and that career was an amazing
wild ride and in some ways felt like,
uh,
you know,
a temporary sidebar from what I'm really
meant to do.
You know,
I've been,
I've been writing for a long time and
um,
yeah,
I think that,
uh,
whatever this thing is that I'm doing
it,
it chose me somehow or I don't know.
Maybe that's,
I don't know if that's true or not,
but I don't know.
How long can you ignore the thing inside
you that screams at you that says you
have to do this,
you have to do this or you want to do,
yeah.
Well,
you shouldn't.
Yeah.
You definitely shouldn't.
I mean it's obviously beneficial and so
obviously something you're compelled to
do and it's obviously something that you
feel is very fulfilling.
So why ignore it?
So when do you start this podcast?
It's out.
What's it called?
It's called the every man podcast.
He every man podcast.
Yep.
Evr Why man?
What about checks?
No fuck off.
Fuck off chicks.
You got your own.
You got Oprah.
Okay.
I know.
I mean,
that's a good question.
I don't think it's uh,
why uh,
why do you spell it that way?
Cause Shit out of people.
Well,
because the full one was like a lot of
money or it wasn't available.
The website,
it was just a practicality thing.
Okay.
Yeah.
E v.
E r.
Y.
M.
A.
N was uh,
not evie.
Our why.
So evr why folks?
Evr Why man podcast?
How many episodes do you have out to now
and then?
Yeah,
to writing.
Are you doing them every week?
Like how are you doing it?
I'm going to try.
It would probably be a every two weeks
to start and then just got to get in the
swing.
You're on itunes.
Yeah,
the whole,
all that jazz.
Beautiful Man.
Yeah.
All right,
well let's wrap it up.
So,
uh,
that's awesome.
It's awesome that it's out there.
It's awesome that people can get ahold
of it.
I always love talking to you,
brother.
So let's do this again.
Yeah.
But thank you.
All right.
Appreciate it,
Dan Dougherty,
ladies and gentlemen,
every man podcast,
we'll be back tomorrow with Daddy.
It's Russell.
See Ya.